[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
might check my check around what's going
on i see y'all up in there early we
little running behind honey they're
already waiting
[Music]
we late what's going on because
[ __ ]
i see the chat
now we good
how about levels hustle what's up bro
audio's good thank you sir appreciate
you yeah we're gonna get this rolling we
got justin in the building we're about
to start in a second so we just gonna
get right
today
all right
and we are live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to
advancedgg.com use code iron lord on the
checkout this is something i use all the
time got to support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go laura
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny worked a
cognito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got
bad news even if you really was that you
can't never still be the king of the
statues since the juvenile i've been
cursed with a curse to be musical and if
you hate it we'll meet in the crucible
was it and nothing is cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursued but whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right you might check your next
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you see did you see when he posted
the picture
yeah that's fine
somebody needed some pledge in their
life
anyway here you hear
me good afternoon good afternoon and
here if we are live welcome to the
island podcast llc and also live on
lordsofgaming.net
episode number 266. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day i'm very excited
about our special guest and we've got
the business of esports a black panther
game by ea
microsoft and sony financials and halo
if
infinite forge leaks to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a rising star with an intellectual
property law and the entertainment
industry
but is truly a multifaceted talent in
video games reminding us all that prior
results do not guarantee a similar
outcome
introducing the entertainment and
esports attorney of the jacobson law
firm and the author of the essential
guide to business law esports and
professional video gaming
the lord of gaming talent and legit
professor of esports business
and the only man that we call jmj
without the kaggle or the shelter adidas
live from new york and kind enough to
make his debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord justin m jacobson how we
doing sir good man thanks for having me
and that was a glorious you know intro i
i don't think i've had one so star
studded by
it
you can play that in the loyal beasts i
just break
[Laughter]
how you doing man moving and shaking and
also like what games you've been playing
man what's been going on with you
good man yeah i'm definitely you know
always been a big 2k guy so that's
always kind of been my game of choice
and you know i have this mobile game
this marvel contest of champions that
just
like been my like side obsession for
like you know six seven years and i'm
how much money how much money you expect
i know that i heard that getting
dangerous you gotta ask that question we
got it
my wife might listen to this
[Music]
okay we have a little confidentiality
thing that i won't tell anybody yeah
never mind
the hundreds of people listening
let's just say that you know i read some
stat that like you know the
quote-unquote average whales like you
know 500 to a thousand on that game
sounds about right yeah
that's about right
he hit the target until
he didn't say cadence though he said
just a hundred thousand he didn't say
how long that goes
what i love is the pause between he's
like sounds about right
what i like is he gave you loyal talk
yeah as a fact he didn't nail it down
and he didn't tell you anything around
it but he gave you a roundabout thought
of it right now
it's good to see you good good to have
you in the realm we got to respect your
time but uh yes get on with it and you
already know we got the four horsemen of
gaming the original lords here of the
realm at the round table kind of
time-sensitive intro because you got to
respect lord jesus
give me your time and shut up
shots damn all right
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict of the attic show how
we doing sir i'm doing pretty good uh
what you guys doing uh
well you got a time on it wow
i did seven seconds man
all right all right
that's shot's fine it's yours that
sounds fine all right cool i see what
you're doing you're done are you
finished are you done quiet
[Laughter]
and um
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus start putting the
camera up that table the lord of clarity
and lord patriot of the iron bank
[Laughter]
uh uh yeah it was a good week up to up
until friday um i lost my aunt
unexpectedly to me
and uh because i just had no idea that
was coming and uh that was tough
i'm sorry but uh yeah beyond that you
know whatever just not whatever but tell
the people you love that you love them
because you just never know
that's right
and but beyond that let me see papa gabe
give it as always papa gable so i'm
getting ready for i'm excited for saints
row the remake coming out on august and
also still gotham nights i still want to
see what wb montreal has up this leaf so
in preparation for that i'm playing
saints row the third on my on my steam
deck okay it's beautiful 60 fps that
gave me bonkers i never played it when
it first came out because i was so tired
of that type of open world by the time
that game came out yeah but going back
to it now
so much fun and the same with arkham
origins i'm playing that as well and
it's like
that game's really good you know i i
don't understand the hate on that game
like it's
it does everything that you expect from
a batman game so really
i don't know but i'm having fun with
that no doubt you already know salute
glad you could make it we know you had a
lot
and uh appreciate you brother and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
better than jose benavidez
shout out to everybody that came out
last night with the support yes i love
it combat talk is a fun thing that we do
like i tell you everybody that shows up
for the first 1k people that do show up
there's a drink inside your refrigerator
take a drink brought to you from me it's
your favorite drink so tune in
have another one if you want
now but um yeah man uh danny garcia he's
one of my favorite fighters to watch i
don't know he has an infectious smile i
love his style uh and yesterday i got a
chance to see a little bit more of danny
garcia i got a chance to see a wrinkle
in his game
danny garcia that couldn't hurt his
opponent that was in front of him
because we know danny garcia has very
heavy hands and what he did yesterday to
break down jose benavidez was uh sort of
masterful he's in his first time uh time
at that uh that weight class suit the
walter weight uh 154 and he boxed danny
was on his toes he was the counter
puncher slick boxer dude that showed me
a different wrinkle to his game that i
haven't seen that he didn't have to show
when he was at walter weight and
it was it was something nice to see um
so
again i don't agree with his pops being
his trainer but yeah so you see him
rejuvenated king because i was kind of
reaching that point with him while it
felt like he's a an old young fighter
you know what i mean like he's been
through a lot of wars and it wasn't
quite the same so you see you see him
sort of rejuvenated no i still see him
as that um
the third rung dude right you have
you have no you have superstars you have
stars
and then you have those champions
right there right so and on any given
night he can beat a champion right can
he beat a superstar i don't believe so
because any time he did step in the ring
with a star he lost
so um you know he beat zab judah so i
and and i put zab judah in his category
as uh uh i got a champion
so you know that that's that's great um
i finish mm-hmm what you play yeah go
guardians of the galaxy oh
let's go i was so sucked into that game
yes
um the story
is very very heartfelt yeah it's a
heartbreaking story because there's a
lot of plot twists in it it lets you
believe one thing until you get to a
precipice and it's not that thing facts
it's it's
it is really i don't even know how they
get uh fired or how they get exercised
out after making a game of that quality
i mean i'm talking about the quality of
the build the graphics graphics
storyline the the connectivity of the
great game the level of banter they're
going back and forth
incredible stuff and then these things
do have repercussions inside the game
because if you don't do a certain thing
for certain people or you do it in the
wrong manner or whatever it has actual
repercussions tell me the 80s vibe when
you even launch the game i'm like i'm
old i had everything in his room
[Music]
of these season passes
i must log in and do work in these
season passes i got destiny
i got um four guys
uh i don't know why the hell i put that
on i'm on the fall guys grime
that sounds like that
that sound like he spit somebody right
there that's that
yes that was the justin hour he was
talking about the analytics at 2k where
he was
[Music]
i mean
i've officially abandoned a couple of
the season passes so now you got one
that's not like he blew his old check
but you gotta think about it right you
gotta think these companies get their
money up front and it's up on you to
finish off the stuff the content there
but then they take it away if you don't
do it in a timely fashion yeah that's
why i like uh halo because they they let
you retain the season pass and do
whatever one you ever you want
and that's that's a good thing and i
haven't heard that you know so they're
good that that season pass i brought
from this video but that's about it
that's all i've been doing um attic and
i have been cooking up some stuff okay
all right guys um and i know uh we we
say it i don't care at it you can put
that up yeah it's time that's great i
told you it's time to take crazy minutes
so your minutes is in there
i'm taking sovereigns extra minutes
uh-huh i'll get my minutes off there
yeah and then you know i'm gonna slide
into uh cogs a little bit yes
but um yeah
and addict putting out he made it go
longer see
idiotic
but
we attic and i is going to do a lot of
uh shows that's with you guys so we're
going to encourage and it's going to be
i'm going to tell you ahead of time so
you don't say oh i didn't warn you
patreon members get the first preference
then realm members is coming in second
coming in hot second
and and if there's any spaces left we're
going to do a community night where
we're going to pick a movie
um and we're going to have everybody
come over and we're going to watch a
movie we're going to go to the movie
theater we're going to have all that
stuff so uh you guys uh it's going to be
one hell of a night all right so you're
gonna have details on that stuff coming
up but i want you all to know that now
and early put the bucket here we're
doing that this is about to be soon no
doubt and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi lord cognito
spread that realism around the ilp not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear shout out to mr maddie
plays who is back from the back injury
defining dude came back this week on
last stand media good show could get a
chance to hear him and then we had a
special defining duke ultimate with a
special member of the realm lord sov
completes the ilp defining duke uh
invasion
and we had a great discussion we were
talking about potential acquisitions
after activision blizzard for microsoft
and soft cape through with flying colors
but i really enjoyed that episode man
you did you think bro
you mute it
sorry you know the bronx yeah oh yeah
they was killing you it was like where
they said it saw doing it from his block
what's happening where is he recording
yo somebody went it was kind of funny i
was like dude it came from a man
i was in the high rise man but you know
he anytime you we recorded on sunday
like after iop so yeah the weekend
summertime in new york city like this it
was popping oh [ __ ] this tree is popping
it was popping
yeah it was it was an awesome time yeah
a lot of fun a lot of good reviews so
like i said without all the lords have
been in the realm um yeah for me uh last
word shout out the last word he bought
this tie guy travis had my man shadow
pull up had a good uh skill-based
matchmaking debate debate on pvp and
what's coming to destiny next season
also for us what what i've been playing
mlb the show got my blue cause you know
the mets run new york
don't
figure your face
i'm a jedi
no my dad grew up on the block okay so
you get a pass you get a pass you get a
pass you're a yankees fan right oh yeah
yeah jokers you know your kids y'all got
it from the cradle he's yankee and jets
like you yeah that's right that's right
that's how you mix it
it's like
you offset it the pavement
i got it's
because i watched them as a kid with 86
and after they've been terrible for so
long i said no more new york teams after
the bets was enough
and then you know as you get older you
start like understanding like
demographics and where you literally let
the team get hot
yes so yeah but i asked my dad i'm like
dad why aren't we yankee fans we live
literally blocks away from the stadium
and then he came you know all the
yankees have been a racist team
shout out to bob duke keeping it loyal
he was like back in the 20s back in the
20s they were all
races you know i i just i couldn't i
couldn't so i tried to be on the line
with both of them
except for cog i've been generally
surrounded by insufferable met fans that
are just dumb so i had to like i just
like i'm i'm yankees all the way thank
you
i'll never forget them losing the
playoffs back to back years on the last
day oh
everyone's just so mad i'm just laughing
like that's what the mets do yeah we
losing the most heartbreaking
yeah you're right yeah absolutely
i just can't wait for this season
it'll happen and then they come back
again so i gotta get there because we
pop off down with the first half that's
right and we talk our talk so we look
like sony fans oh damn so here we go
anyway move it all because top on me
addict will put the top on me but yeah
i'm gonna do it because of my men's love
i'm doing a whole bunch of mlb the show
2022 my march to october getting my
season going you know what i'm saying
then i'm gonna finish that probably
switch to the video for you though oh
well you know shout out the game pass
you know what i'm saying phil dominus
maximus aurelia spencer got you he
hooked you up with that daily little boy
what's the name of that game about the
show 22. that's a sony product listen
shout out to phil he did promise me that
at e3 2015 that they will correct the
baseball fan baseball game simulation
baseball game situation phil told me to
my face shout out to phil whatever y'all
dude mlb i love that contract i [ __ ]
y'all finally have a simulation
i actually
anyway but i get to play my bench and
then on the rocker blade point man the
rocker blade point is my game justin
when are you going to invite me to play
yo we got to schedule up now just our
schedules are different but at the end
no bro you got it always online it's
just i'm invisible because dudes we do
not say anything
it'd be crazy but um it's funny because
i want justin's take on it eventually
maybe not this show but because this
thing i didn't know how big an esports
thing this thing was in japan like the
rocket play point is a thing over there
you know what i'm saying japan so um
yeah i've been rocking that they got a
new map coming up with a new campaign
mode and yeah that's been pretty much it
let's get the super chats off let's get
rocking
that hold on one second i copy paste
today so we started with elliot [ __ ]
it's remember for 27 months thank you
bro brother can't believe it's been more
than two years since i've tuned always a
pleasure to tune into this fantastic
show keep up the good work brothers
thank you brother appreciate that thank
you
we got donald taco 10 super chat just
your weekly reminder that nintendo's
2022 exclusive lineup is better than the
entire ps5 series lineup since launch
and xenoblade chronicles 3 is the only
competition for eldon ring this year yo
switch gaggers in the building today
make sure you get your cataract
prescription
well you thought you implying that the
resolution is not up to you i'm just
implying that there's a lot of doctors
do we got to bring the i got doctor i
got back on the show
like i i haven't even seen the game and
i'm implying with you man it's not there
switch coming in hot continues very high
on fire that's where it's coming good
speculation what up
there we go eagles fan 76 five dollar
super chat jim ryan are you committed to
keeping the ps5 at the current price or
raising it jim ryan this is a quote from
jim ryan let me back let me get back to
you no further questions conference over
i don't know if that interview was
confirmed
people are making their own narratives
but okay
thank you my brother appreciate it thank
you
cogs since you liked yakuza um
uh what the hell is like a dragon like a
dragon i'm sorry yeah you should really
play uh
zero through six as well worth it it's
not like there are any games coming out
oh damn i got zero through six are very
different but but then like a dragon
it's definitely action games hold on
hold on hold on hold on what happened
here
how are you gonna ask us
it's like yo you like that that that
turn base that rpg stuff we're gonna
have you play something completely
completely different here completely
different sort of the huggie though he
tried he tried to get me get get all my
yakuza you know i mean it is what it is
what else we got
yeah we're caught up all right cool
let's get this rocket guest has been
extremely patient through our intro
so
now that we've gotten into what the
lords have been playing i want to focus
on lord justin his video game system
history his journey into the
entertainment business and intellectual
property and of course what led him to
one becoming one of the most prominent
video game attorneys in the esports
scene so lord justin let's start from
the very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
well yeah so i've definitely been a
lifelong gamer i'm starting with
nintendo oldest memories of like holding
the duck hunt gun against the screen
because little justin i guess thought
that that would make me get the duck
quicker if i had the i had the gun right
against the tv
so you know then from there to sega to
you know n64 and xbox always been the
xbox guy and now i have xbox and
playstation and you know it's always
kind of been part of you know what me my
friends do big you know madden 2k fifa
starcraft and starcraft 2 was definitely
my kind of you know computer game of
choice i would say and
yeah i mean it was definitely like every
year because i need the new 2k and the
new madden
so let's slow it down for a second
because you're moving like light speed
yeah he's going through it right um and
i'm gonna peg you down
um
what was your first console
nintendo oh all
[Laughter]
around stuff man you gotta be real good
with them all right pause um
what was the first games that you was
enjoying during that what that was that
um something that you you got for
christmas or what was your earliest
experience with it
i mean i would say definitely played a
lot of dollcon but i feel like that was
probably when i was you know a little
bit younger i would say sega is probably
when i really
like you know got to really rich yeah
damn
[ __ ] watch it yo you got it
it was usually either or right well no
this is later i would say okay you know
like say it was a little bit later but
yeah i mean
definitely was you know sega was a big
one so like you know nhl 94 was wrong
what about the genesis yeah yeah all
right so what okay
what made you look into genesis
direction
i mean because you're a nintendo dude
and it brought you a lot of joy right
you would say right what made you look
over to the black box to i don't know
and the super i guess it was between
like either you know super nintendo or
genesis and
i don't know i guess sonic was probably
you know it was like you got the sonic
bundle nice no i felt like you know
super nes like i didn't really even like
that controller like really the gray
with the forward and the phone yeah like
i don't know and then like
definitely you got obsessed with you
know sega so you know yeah toe jam and
earl oh an aladdin game
that was when the game you know that was
when game genie actually made life
amazing shout out to james shout out to
game g to get them cheats off yes yes
yeah but i ain't gonna let you skip
through he built
and then you have to you know going to
the website and stuff like that but i
don't want to let him skip through
because
with the he said nhl 94 which is
arguably the greatest hockey game of all
time they had to play a license the
fights the blood the whole thing like so
would you say the genesis because of
let's be honest the sports games were
really superior at that time like the
lakers versus celtics i believe was it
a bunch of times
yeah like was the sports scene
really a part of why you got into the
ecosystem or was it just other things as
well
i mean i think it was just other things
as well but like that was that game
where like you had to outlaw that move
where you went to the boards and spun
around cause you could score every time
you know so it was just like i you know
i was a big hockey guy you know playing
roller hockey and stuff so absolutely
oh so you played real hockey yeah roller
hockey you know i would roller hockey
rich kid hockey
right
because it formulates the the narrative
his narrative exactly it's not my
narrative he was affluent because he had
these things let me tell you something
it was either all with your friends you
had the nintendo dude you go to his
house yeah the sega dude you go to his
house or you had my friend which was
calvin who had all that so we all went
to calvin house because calvin had a
little bit more money than we did so he
was our calvin uh-huh this is what i'm
talking about let's let's get back to
our calendar
what is the sound effect what is going
on what's happening in the plane who's
landing the plane
anyway i have no clue where that came
from yeah that's attic doing something
no it really isn't okay anyway moving on
so what did you hear uh what did you
hear it's not like a plane it's not like
a plague was just
are you sure you don't hear my ac maybe
that was that ac sound like that you got
to take it back to the store bro that
sound like we was that laguardia
it's like it was after it's still
continuing now it's good it was like it
wasn't that it
okay so you got that you do genesis
you're going 64. i'd say n64 is when it
really kind of okay now we talk
you know leveled up to you know super
mario gretzky nfl blitz
i think zelda ocarina of time was like
the first game that i super super got
obsessed with it's like you know aol fan
club
like all that like super upset like
that was probably like the one that'll
always like be like yeah zelda ocarina
of time that's like
so let me ask the younger contingent
here um lord addict do we approve of
lord justin's
n64 love ocarina is that is that
satisfactory yeah but i'm just curious
why you keep asking me every time
someone brings up occurring at time like
i've answered this like 80 times i just
find it interesting i just find it
interesting that you wake up as soon as
someone say n64 and it acts like
anything else didn't exist i wasn't in
diapers
[Laughter]
okay so you go from there you got 64.
you know what i mean an xbox
nba live 05 with melo on it is still
probably the best basketball game i
would video game that was like the end
of live live 06 was just so gimmicky and
terrible
i remember it was just like all the
stupid power of stuff power ups like
that you would just be yeah and that was
then when 2k just blew it out the water
from there yeah now let's just backtrack
a second you didn't were you did you
mess with the dreamcast at all when 2k
debut oh so g cast was not part of your
okay no dream yes i was xbox not
playstation again like
i like i feel like i would break that
controller you know i'm a big dude like
that controller is more amazing yeah the
duke is for the big hit
i'm starting to see a pattern here all
right here we go um he saw the
controller for the nintendo and was like
no i like this big-handed controller he
saw the uh the n64 no 64 had a big ring
with the joint in the middle yeah you're
right king the controller draws him in
yes uh dictates
yes good point
all right let's
let
the uh everyone know that the witness
has stated
the controller
controller with and girth matters
oh my god
that the record statement
falls
[Laughter]
so there we go from there you got kind
of stay in the xbox and did you get the
playstation eventually though did you
know i've got playstation 4 eventually
you know that's probably what i you know
use the most he did eventually he said
it begrudgingly like well no it's just
like i always had xbox x360 xbox one and
then it was like oh well i kind of need
like a netflix kind of thing in the
bedroom so let's go to playstation
questions
but he said nothing
you messy bro you messy i love this guy
anyway
we're gonna clip that part right there
you want to cut that off for your xbox
propaganda sir that's not doing that
that my friend justin is the reason that
they kill us on xbox podcast exactly
that's why we all get looped in exactly
so cool
we guilty by association
with a dog to get fleece
the gameboy and the gameboy color and
the game gear really portable's okay
yeah yeah yeah you were at sleepway cam
so you needed it right to play you know
a lot of tetris definitely pokemon
oh my god tetris is just like all right
he's
out the button is
talked about that tetris that portable
livestream talk to me about that
time we got we got we got time
restraints
i love that you do the portables like we
don't get a lot of people talking about
the the impact of what
yeah mobile game is huge like it's like
out of control like everyone like i was
you know reading this book it's like
two-thirds of the world has a smartphone
like
of the world not even america like of
the world
you know so it's just like mobile gaming
is just enormous no doubt tremendous
gaming history i know we could get in
there talk for a long time hold on look
like someone gotta shout somebody out
someone did pick up some merch but um
yeah shout out the classic iop you know
what i'm saying salute to you on that
mercy already oh that works yeah yeah
how did i get my third for that they
must have got it
we work out we work out your deal after
the show
[Laughter]
the shopping tab thing like you can
actually put like
stuff in these oh okay oh that's what's
up yeah because i just saw it pop up so
i just thought that because i put it in
the chat and then someone bought it so
clearly
you already know so now we got we have
obviously tremendous gaming history we
could sit there talk all day about that
but i want to get into your career a
little bit before obviously what you're
kind of known for which is esports and
being in that field but i want to talk
about kind of
music business you got a little start
there i wanted to know i want you to
educate people like how did that journey
kind of start for you before gaming well
yeah so you know i i've been an attorney
so an entertainment and esports attorney
for the last decade and i started more
in the traditional music and sports
world working with um some producers and
songwriters and djs and
record labels and talent matters it's
all kind of you know individuals in that
a lot of hip hop and edm dance music and
just kind of grow up
give me some artists though
i flipped flex
anyway
you know the warners and the sonys and
the universals of the world and you know
atlantic records and all these major you
know companies and so really involved in
all that and did some stuff with some
pro athletes um some
nfl and nba guys and some fashion
designers and celebrity stylists and
there's a lot of creative people and
always as i've mentioned always been a
lifelong gamer so as i'm kind of on my
journey i'm you know working with all
these different talent and
kind of what was going on in like the
esports world you know kind of came to
my radar like i always knew that you
know starcraft and starcraft 2 was huge
in like south korea and asia and that
like you know over there those pro
gamers are like you know lebron and
here
where like they're like you know super
star level kind of stuff but it wasn't
until about you know six seven years ago
did i really start to see growing here
in north america and you know in the u.s
and
kind of looked at what was out there and
noticed a lot of the especially
attorneys and professionals in it were
all very similar they all kind of had a
very similar background like you know
born and bred esports and gaming people
you know their clients were their former
gamer friends and you know i kind of
came from working with you know jets and
giants and you know major rappers and
you know people that are kind of
assigned to these five six figure
publishing deals doing all of these you
know really nice appearances and such
and kind of had a different network a
different approach and kind of just a
totally different mindset to this and
fun i just started to notice a lot of
similarities between
you know how you would work with you
know pro gamer or streamer and what you
would with a musician a lot of the
similarities between you know the
organizations like the hundred thieves
and faze clans and some of the def jam
and rockefeller and bad boy records that
like you know it's much more than we're
wearing a jersey like you are the jets
it's like a cultural way of life it's
like i'm down with rockefeller like
you know it's like
much more of a cultural community thing
and that just kind of let me use my
knowledge from both and just from there
i've just been just kind of working with
you know players and teams and coaches
and on-air talent and you know helping
them make it all happen no that's fine i
wanted to um kind of help you know my
generation obviously you know i'm a gen
xer and we have some in in the chat that
you know
the older variety the mature variety and
some of them could be like yo
why should i even care about this
esports thing like like what's the thing
like so like why
you talk kind of about the pillars of it
right in in the caches and the
organizations and stuff like that but
like why should people care about what's
going on in your opinion like why is
this something that we should really put
a fingerprint on and see and track where
this thing is going as far as he sports
i mean i think it's one of these big
conversations where you know the gaming
world is just everything involved in the
video game stuff which is kind of a lot
of the conversations that you have and
you know esports is much more of you
know the holly competitive
individuals kind of taking this a
profession where it's like day in and
day out they're grinding they're playing
the game they're watching strategies
they're watching you know vods and
replays and learning what they did wrong
and looking at analytics and kind of
straight you know like doing these
scrimmages to kind of work different
plays whether it's you know nba 2k
league where they're practicing plays
like you would an nba team where you're
doing off ball screens and all kinds of
defensive shifts or you know a call of
duty or league of legends where you're
you know learning what moves different
people use and how to counter them and
how you bait different stuff and just
kind of what persons go to if you know
if they're in a gunfight or they know to
come at you and shoot or they're more
likely to kind of block and retreat it's
just like you know these advanced
analytics are what you know the
professional athletes look at and this
whole sabermetrics conversation and you
know all of these so they're kind of
bringing it over to you know competitive
gaming and i think what a lot of people
like about it is it's almost activating
your like super hyper fans like yeah you
may like league of legends but to see
people competing at a game that you love
at like a super high level implementing
strategies that you know maybe you're
familiar with or like let's be real we
go to youtube the same way we used to go
to gamestop to buy the how to build the
zelda box like that primary strategy
they go to youtube and it's like oh how
do i do this dribble move or what's the
best weapon or what's the best you know
skin what you know all these what's the
best character like you know in the
marvel game i was talking about the
youtubers always put down like a new
character breakdown where they show you
the strengths of it and you know kind of
what their moves look like and oh this
new character's great or like you know
after they nerfed for character what it
looks like
so it's just like
the people that really care about games
at that high level want to see
people competing at the highest level
yeah it's like if you're a basketball
fan you want to watch you know lebron
and you know all these super duper
people that like yeah maybe you can dunk
maybe shoot a three but none of us can
dunk or shoot or do what kind of stuff
like these guys can like you see steph
curry like shooting a half-court shot
like it's me and you shooting a layup
where he's just like
nonchalance
like swish like keeps it moving
so it's just like
that level of expertise and
you know
high level performance you know people
love and you know actually i'm sure you
guys are familiar with him todd harris
he was the you know the co-ceo of hi-rez
studios i actually had him on my show
and he talked about um a study that they
had commissioned with some emory phds
that kind of showed a correlation
between games that have esports and
don't and kind of the spending patterns
transition right into that okay yeah the
spending patterns of people that follow
the esports in the game and that don't
that that if you follow a game that has
an esport the people that follow that
esport and still play the game end up
spending a substantially lot more money
because whether it's battle passes skins
or you just care about that game more so
you want to play it more and as a result
you want to be good at it you want to
you know the same way these kids buy
every single fortnight skin it's like
what's different between the spider-man
between the wolverine between the you
know the fins like there's no like it's
just the image but kids want 10
different ones because one day they want
to be spider-man one day they want to be
you know justin jefferson doing his move
the next day they want to be iron man
and it's just kind of like
you know you know so it's just
that's kind of the reason that it like
really activates your hypersensitive and
in the music business they call it a
true fan like there's the thousand true
fan theory that if you get a hundred
bucks from your thousand true fans you
make a hundred g's that's your six
figures
and
you could
you know succeed as a creator off that
kind of income absolutely did y'all guys
hear that sorry what he said uh we have
400 people that's here
like and share and then um i want a
hundred of
buy some merch maybe you want to join
100
jesus king
we got to test his theory
i want to put his theory into practice
because
they go on there and they play like it's
the same thing as destiny you go on
there you play regular regular crucible
you get masterful the casual players
that's one thing people don't realize
the the dedication it takes to be in
like the top of us
of an esports like it's crazy like i i
advise you to go look at like those
those halo tournaments like like that
that that stuff's crazy like you think
oh like
oh yeah these guys are just like you
know i watch some of their streams and
even some of the females i represent
they are unbelievable like these girls
are unbelievable and i know that they
will beat 99 percent of the guys that
think they're good at this factual yeah
well i mean we have to get out of that
whole thought pattern that girls can't
play video games first of all that's
that's far from the absolute truth uh
because
it's it's i it has to be dedication to
the player whoever the player is because
i've seen uh uh handy-enabled people
actually are some of the top people in
some places and you know shout out to
microsoft for getting that controller
that they're able to access adaptive
control yeah we had an interview
solomon romney developed it yes yeah
excellent perfect stuff um no um please
uh take away your prejudice because you
go in there with a preconceived notion
you're going to get smoked like a
cigarette yeah
yeah it's just like
yeah
like nothing like i'm just watching the
stream it's just like headshot after
headshot like one shot killed beast and
then yeah like you gotta take into
consideration like you know you you see
this stuff and you know it looks
intimidating but it's worse for them
because like when you it's like i said
when you go on play the these crucible
matches you're playing against other
people generally mo more like you but
like imagine playing trials of osiris
with sweaties all the time a hundred
percent of the time yeah yeah it's that
bracket yeah but the high level of our
in league of legends like you're queuing
like you're going to be playing against
pros that are just on stream playing it
and like they don't want to lose on
stream
people are super sweaty like
like they are not trying to lose
so like i'm sorry sorry just so yeah
like you know there's players that like
sometimes i link them up with like some
of the pro athletes and it's like
they're getting 20 30 kills in a war
zone round and the athlete's like yo i
don't want to play with them because i'm
getting like two kills yeah and it looks
so like yeah
30 kills i'm getting two it's like you
know what's funny justin like there's
this thing in uh gaming uh it's it's got
skill base like a lot of games have it
i love when there's debates on whether
or not a game casual playlist should
have it or not like so you don't want to
play people with your skill like you
only want to play people on your skill
or below your skill level skill based
matchmaking it's a hot it's a hot topic
for sure i saw he was going to jump in
yeah i mean justin
my my sort of ears perked up when you
said sabermetrics because i sabermetrics
is you know
generally just known as a baseball way
of of measuring sort of worth um
and skill is like is
are they literally applying those same
sort of algorithms and stuff to gaming
because it's it's kind of i mean again i
think that stuff can be applied
generally but i just didn't realize it
was being applied in that way especially
when you look at esports obviously these
guys are amazing players but a lot of it
to me just looking at it from the
outside it felt it feels like it's just
like young guys with super you know
with the ability to practice all the
time and with you know super fast
reflexes and stuff
it
looking at it just feels like it's kind
of a youth and sort of reflex thing i
never really even thought about and you
know as somebody who who's played
fighting games and stuff like that
obviously there are techniques and stuff
like that there's this strategy
obviously but it just it is muscle
memory right
i didn't realize that that sort of app
that sort of uh
those sort of metrics were applied to
game play here well yeah i mean that's
kind of a two-parter to that you know a
lot of these games have you know api
where you can get all this advanced
metrics like right you could see you
know what your splatter radius is when
you do a smoke like you know what you're
you know how how many boats you use
versus how many kills like there's all
these advanced things and that's how a
lot of you know these academy teams and
there's individuals that really just
look at these analytics and they could
tell if you're doing really high in
certain categories that you're more
likely going to be successful and that's
kind of the correlation of sabermetrics
so they okay and what i think is really
unique about this is you know some of
the nfl players i talk to with like the
difference between being good i mean you
know great is so small it's in the
littlest mannerisms it's you know i
remember revis always used to say that
shout out to you he always could write
randy moss because he always he had to
tell whenever he was ready to go out for
his pass his body was loose his hands
were like
more like hey i'm ready to go but when
he had a block for a run
he kind of was already bracing to do the
wrong stuff
his hands were in front of him
he wasn't like ready to run and that
would always be how you'd be able to
tell and it's that littlest thing that
you have to literally have to watch a
thousand
you know snacks
looking for that one thing for that one
tell me and then he was able to own
those people remember that year when it
was rivas island oh my listen every best
wide receiver was just like like you
just couldn't blame him in fantasy if
you're watching he was playing rebus it
was just like it was a wrestler
where you were gonna get one catch for
two yards and i love that stuff because
you know as a sports guy and even i know
you guys just fit my favorite position
is is the quarterback position and i
feel like it's a very thankless job and
you're defending the best athlete and on
the on the other side so this here you
break that down with the analytics and
looking for the tells and looking for
percentages or on what's effective and
seeing this now applied on this saber
metric level to gaming is pretty
exciting because it's like it again we
come from the laws a lot of us come from
i know atticus is competitive yugioh you
know us we come from like a very
competitive tekken scene right hi-lo oh
okazami what's more effective frame data
you know what i'm saying all that kind
of stuff right and to see this thing
continue to evolve now with fps and all
this stuff exciting what i wanted to ask
you though just real quick real quick is
you mentioned something earlier about
how
game development in terms of having
publishers want to kind of get into as
far as having these esports type service
games do you think like
with the rise of esports right is that
truly influencing because i look at like
sony just acquired bungie right and they
want to do 10 live service games that's
one of the things that they're talking
about but what they did first was they
acquired eva evolved correct screen that
was
the reason is because you know the laws
changed in japan
you couldn't play esports it was
considered gambling it was like
so that's why i feel like sony's finally
started to make their play into esports
is because all the local laws have kind
of cleared up right so you got that and
then you know me and you had discussion
obviously shout out to you know call of
duty league and i'm seeing a high level
play of these kids i'm like what is
going on this is insane what these kids
are doing and i look at microsoft with
their recent potential closing of the
activision blizzard king acquisition
right which would then in turn make from
a marketing perspective give microsoft
xbox kind of control of that once the
dust settles with the with the legality
so do you see like
these acquisitions being thought about
from publishers with esports in mind so
that maybe they could catch a wave and
you know we know there's licenses
involved that they get a little money
you know saying with their games like
what do you think about this whole thing
as far as the acquisition influence
yeah i mean i think when you see power
players like sony buying evo be like
okay you know that's a fighting game you
know it's not just like call of duty
it's all fighting games that's the
ability to start you know using whatever
is popular starting to cycle in their
own stuff you know they i know the sony
playstation 5 became the official
console for the 2k league which you know
so that that was like another
opportunity for them to pick okay well
all these pros are playing 2k on our
system and you know like they didn't
need to do that but you know i think
that it was just a way for them to kind
of put their footprint in a lot of
places and ultimately
i think a lot of this stuff you know
even like i'm reading the book on the
metaverse it all kind of ties into user
acquisition and just getting people into
your ecosystems and you know giving them
more reasons to be in your digital game
pass xbox live world
you know like the longer that your game
console is turned on the more you're
engaging with it the more opportunity
they can make money off of you so the
more games they have the more events you
know the more hype around it just kind
of like feeds the machine you know like
esports i feel like the game developers
always look at it as like a marketing
tool where it's like hey everyone come
check out this call of duty week and
look at how great these kids are but you
should go buy your new call of duty game
that comes out in six months and like
use it as a way to do that
but now they're seeing it as more of
almost like
a way to kind of engage with the youth
to create
like another vertical within their
business that like you know where you're
kind of making on with you know
microsoft it's like you know activision
blizzard started these franchise leagues
it had you know these 20 30 million
dollar buy-ins and
you know to kind of just take that and
continue with it is just like
you know you have this whole built-in
money-making vessel really no absolutely
fantastic points and um definitely on
one to continue on as far as like you
talk about the business side we see that
but then i want to kind of talk about
the professional esports athlete right
these kids now they're coming out you
know
and now
even i think you even had a post that i
saw that was very interesting like the
ncaa providing like a clear path for
these kids as far as you know likenesses
and image you know in the past that
wasn't the thing
and as you know you this is going on
you're hearing stories about now even
like 26 year olds 26 year old kid
talking about turning high school gamers
into professional esports star so you
see it almost on this grass root high
school
and and college level and my question is
like how
can these kids kind of like protect
themselves because let's be honest like
it's like don't you kind of like the
agent now like
now that this we're getting into the
esports athlete aspect like can you
touch on that can you elaborate on that
growth of what you're seeing trends wise
well yeah you know as a result of you
know the industry growing so big you
know you have multi-million dollar prize
pools you have you know players making
you know five six figures a year salary
if not more if you look at the forbes
list you have you know probably 10 15
people making 10 to 15 to 20 million
dollars a year that you know people like
ninja and shroud and you know pewdiepie
and dr disrespect some of these people
that i wouldn't necessarily are
professional gamers in the same way you
would be you know league of legends
player for team liquid but their
their profession is video games and
gaming and it fits into the world of you
know what i'm doing so as a result of
making these you know large sums of
money and you know signing agreements
with you know big fortune 500 companies
you know from the red bulls to mercedes
to audi to mcdonald's to mountain dew to
you know every brand that you guys can
imagine that
you know sponsors a sports team would
probably be interested in you know
esports there's a lot of similarities in
kind of the marketing techniques so the
fact that everything is just kind of
growing to this point similar to every
other talent world whether it's you know
music sports you know modeling
tv movies there's this whole series of
professionals that service these talents
you know attorneys like myself
there's agents and managers and business
managers and cpas and people that really
just focus on these creative
entertainment worlds
because there are certain needs certain
you know vernacular just certain
experience that you need to understand
to be in these worlds right you know if
you're negotiating an esports player
contract you need to know what other
comparable players are getting it's not
like the nfl the nba where all the stuff
is public every player is signing the
same collectively bargaining agreement
that the you know the nflpa or the nba
pa negotiates the only thing that
changes is the name and how much money
you're getting right but with these
agreements and what's you know unique
and kind of you know what brought my
book about was that it's kind of
you know there is no standards every
team every league every game has their
own agreement you know if people are
using the same lawyer which kind of
happened at the beginning as i was kind
of alluding to a lot of the agreements
started to be the same with different
variations and
you know
the book that i wrote kind of goes into
some of that and is meant to kind of
give a look into what's going on in the
space going through the anatomy of a
player contract and
coach and caster and try to kind of
highlight what's going on here because
this stuff is so impactful and because
you're talking about real money and if
you're making up 50 or 100 bucks you
know like okay but if you're making you
know i was looking at call of duty
contracts the kids were making 250 to
300 000 a year two-year deals and that's
just salary that's not including room
and board
and you know all the merch and that's
just literally into your account
my question to you do you think that
there should be a league
um
standard
now i'm not talking about the league
that actually encompasses and puts
together
the the product that they're playing i'm
talking about a league as far as like
let's let's say let's use the nfl or the
nba right
and they have a standard they have your
your rookie standards you you have your
base minimum and you know you have uh
protections in place for uh these
individuals uh that's going into the
league right uh is is something like
that in place when it comes to these
leagues uh
because from what i'm hearing it sounds
like the wild wild west right it sounds
like if tommy is really the hot
commodity and he's viewed as like jordan
uh he doesn't have a base going in
he goes in with his metrics and his
numbers and he's accordingly compensated
at that point
uh do you believe that a base would be
bad
because we don't know if uh tommy is
only good for two years right and then
uh puberty kicks in and his reflex is
going for a different direction and he
no longer attacks a uh um
a scenario in the same manner because my
son and i and i only say this because
when we're playing uh um fortnight let's
say fortnight i use my pub g experience
when i'm playing it i'm more cautious
i'm more look at it and strategize my
son is gung-ho he has absolutely no fear
in in in the depth of the video game
because where i come from
we care about that one up right we care
about that that life bar we care about
that he doesn't care he can let that old
go he doesn't care pick up my car daddy
and bring me back to life so i can kill
some more people um
so do you think that uh um a contract
over a long period of time for any
individual be detrimental to tommy's uh
zeitgeist moment or do you think
individual contracts should be based on
performance
well yeah so you know what's nice is
some of the leagues like you know the
overwatch league and the call of duty
league have implemented minimum salaries
where a player will get a minimum of 50k
a year plus you know 401k health
insurance like some of these kind of
standard benefits but again it's a
minimum so you have players making
substantially more than that and you
know that way you know you could be a
team that just signs all minimum players
again it's like you can't like undercut
the market and be like okay you're on a
professional team but i'll give you 500
bucks because you're on the t like it
gives you that bottom but there is no
top and there's no salary cap so it's
not like
and the thing about these agreements and
why you know the biggest point of where
someone like me comes in
is that there's just so much flexibility
because there are no standards where
like you know they could probably drop
you whenever they want they can bend you
and cut half your money so like there's
a lot of stuff that these teams can do
and because it's so fragmented
like there can't be just like an esports
wii union or players association because
every game is different games come and
go you know what's popular now might not
be popular in a month or a year or six
years like i always use the example and
i teach of h1z1 when that was like this
huge game there's a huge pro league all
these teams spent a million dollar
buy-in signed players signed coaches and
then pubg fortnite and
you know
came through and they lost 90 of their
user base overnight and that was the end
of the league and all the teams dropped
the players and if you were pro h1z1
player the next night you were not you
were not a pro anymore that was a sony
product right
but the point is that's like a prime
example of how you literally were going
to be a compensated player making you
know a couple thousand dollars a month
to now your game has no value because
fortnite and pub g and you know apex and
all these other you know battle royales
come out and everyone wants to play
those
and that's that no like
that's real that's real and i i love
what you said you know in reference to
you know how it's
you know the protections that have to be
in place when they have to deal with
that's why your service is valued that's
what we're going to talk about your book
because
you're dropping a lot of game here and
i'm just thinking about like yo if i'm
that guy and you know i'm one of the
best on the team and then you know
either you don't want to get paid like
me right but you don't say but let's
just say that they get the new hot kid
right he gets kd better than mine in two
years they like all right kyle we're
gonna put you to the bench like my
salary could change you know what i said
or or i'm just thinking about okay you
know what it's not working they're not
i'm not the star no more and i want to
move on i want to go to clubs such as
such you know what i mean that's
interesting like am i locked in like
yeah they can trade you there's bio
clauses there's no trade clauses like
it's like the m it's like a lot of this
stuff has become like sports where like
you can have a no trade clause where you
know there's certain areas that you
won't go to like you know if you're a
north american player maybe you don't
want to get traded to the korea
overwatch team have to move to seoul
hey
like you might like this is a global
league where they have teams in china
and korea and you know europe and
america so it's like
you know if you're traded from you know
the la team to the paris team and paris
team is in paris yeah you're going to
paris so quick question though not the
country but like what if like can you ca
have you seen scenarios where like kids
are like
they're part of the overwatch league
right they signed with one team but
let's just say they really nice at call
of duty or some other game can you be in
a scenario where you are a part of
multiple teams for different games i
mean you
you can i mean some of the girls i
represented competed in cs go and
valerian
but like they said they picked just
valerian because they started to see
that it was just too hard to be that
proficient to practice and scrim got it
on both games at that level
that it becomes like you can't just be
good enough that you want to be because
a lot of these tournaments as we know
it's very first prize second prize like
if you're not at the top you're maybe
gonna get 500 you know you're gonna get
very minimal stuff if you're in fourth
fifth sixth seventh tenth play like
like the dota two prize pool the
international everyone always totes it's
like the 40 million dollar prize pool
it's like the winning team gets 15 to 20
mil
and like you know divided by five people
you're each making three and a half
million dollars
you literally wake up overnight and
become a multi-millionaire and it's just
kind of like the teams that are
finishing 10th maybe they're getting 150
g's but it ain't no 20 million you know
yeah
so it's just kind of like
it's like being in it
next year i'm
no so i'm saying that it's just like
there's so much fluctuation and it's you
know always kind of saying why the
sabermetrics things kind of comes in
is in you know let's say football or
basketball if you have the biggest
strongest fastest dudes more times than
not you're going to win obviously their
strategy and you know composure and
whatever
but if you have you know the fastest
strongest lebron like you're probably
going to win in sports but in esports
the game is the great equalized yeah
like you you i can't move faster in the
game than you can i can only move as
fast as the game allows me to do
like you know even if i train super
super hard i'm not going to be able to
run faster in the game than you right
whereas if i train super people hard i
may be able to run faster in real life
or
go shoot and so it's like you know
that's where these you know tradable
skills and just the studying and the
metrics and the strategy and how you
play stuff and you know to bring it all
back to the beginning of you know the
nfl comparison and like from going from
college it's like it's the little
details it's the execution it's how you
handle the stress and the pressure it's
like
you know the baseball thing are you
going to shake off the last home run as
a pitcher or you're going to now give up
another one and then another one and
you're going to spiral down it's like
you just got you got in a gunfight and
you lost are you going to be shooking
for the rest of the match
or are you i mean
it's like
you know what the game glitch like i
can't believe i shot him i shot him
first i know i shot him first
but the game didn't think you did and
you died and yeah are you gonna be
thinking about that for the rest of the
game
okay we gotta we gotta regroup we have
to get back to strategy like you know
next pitch kind of thing yeah so it's
like one of those things where it's like
it was so close are you going are you
going to let that dominate your mind for
the rest of the tournament
and let's let's say like because and
when i used to do competitive yugioh it
was like you know
you
you would lose that first round and now
you got to win the next two back to back
so
it's just like you know are you going to
let the fact that you know
you're going to second guess yourself
exactly i can't believe i played that
card you're thinking about that like i
was thinking about like poke rock i'm
always thinking about the bad beat where
it's like you should not have been in on
that
that sort of paid me like what are you
doing and it's like
are you doing
your clients before you hire them to
find out if they you know if they
have they exhibit that type of behavior
that you don't want inside your clients
like you know he's always in his head
after he gets shot in the face twice
yeah i mean i definitely look for people
that are guests are a bit you know safer
like i don't like a dude who's raging
for someone that's gonna stay around for
but we have said that we're going to
replace the window okay so we're okay on
that end he knows he shouldn't have done
it
listen this is this is this is that's so
fascinating
i'm sorry
i'm just going to ask you like you know
let's say that someone's wanting to come
on like the roots of esports like
obviously not in esports but they wanted
to eventually have the end game to play
for esports team do you have any advice
for them
yeah i mean i think that what's nice
about it and also what's hard about is
that there's no like path to pro like
there is in sports was like you play aau
ball then you play to high school then
you get recruited to college and if you
do well and you go to the combine like
you could get drafted or the thing about
esports is that there's like a lot of
paths and i think that that's what's
cool is that like you could be you know
a random team that makes a tournament
and you win the tournament or do really
well in it and now when esports or was
like oh wow like this is a good new kid
this great team like we're gonna sign
him you know and then there's this more
kind of you know academy based on um
analytics
that like you know a lot of these teams
look at the leaderboard they see who's
trending
who's near the top who's the new names
that
are doing stuff how consistently are
they doing averaging okay okay continue
you know this sounds yeah you can't you
can't lose you can't lose two three
rounds in a row attacking
all the rounds
right immortal that like level league of
legends so like pretty much once you
start getting to these super high levels
of these skill based
um matchmaking or like you know when
you're the back in the day of the gamer
you know bad game battles leaderboards
like you'll start to see similar names
at the top and then you start to see new
names out of nowhere
and it's like that's the next
uh
professional life cycle of the average
player
that's as you know the nfl is three to
five years
you know um and anything else three to
five minutes
three to five minutes
that's why baseball's the goat thank you
oh my god
you have people that's 45 years old
still out there pitching
that's right and making 25 million
dollars a year to do it guaranteed
i think i think a lot of us
is just you know keeping up with that
competition like obviously i don't watch
sports but you know clearly they got
training camps they got all this like if
you just go in there because you had
skill one point then you're like okay
now now i'm gonna eat pizza and watch tv
for eight months and not play anything
not keep my reflexes up because i mean i
think we
you know some of us have you know play
games like destiny you you stop playing
that trials that first couple match is
going to be rough
imagine that even two times 100.
like you got it like it takes me like
maybe a quarter to get back into
you know
pick and roll on point the flow of the
game the double you know make sure i
don't over pursue on reach honest you
know like right especially if you
haven't played for a week or oh yeah oh
yeah muscle memory getting in the flow i
wanted to transition because you know we
talked about it a couple times about
your book and i thought it's very
important i think that you know for me
taking a look at it it's just you're
giving game you're giving game out you
know as far as how's this bottle is
going and the thing i didn't realize is
i i always think about esports just from
uh okay the athlete you know this is the
top kid in this you know the stream or
whatever but there's more pillars to it
right and and one thing that people
don't realize like i know one thing i
look king and solve remember this like
one i won't know if i could do it now
but one thing i used to love doing is
when we do the competitive stuff
just commentating
oh
hey pull out the high low combo into
this look like that shout casting stuff
it reminds me of like you know when
you're watching the espn you know the
commentator and they have a knowledge of
the game but they also have the
entertainment aspect when there's a
moment you know what i'm saying bottom
of the knife three two okay you know
those kind of things so yankees wins see
there you go
oh then i gotta hear frank sinatra
moving on but um you got the right idea
you got the right idea but yes like
explain about your book and then like
about the pillars that other people
because there's more to this stuff teams
organizations so much to getting into
the esports thing besides just being
your i'm a good professional player and
i did put his book in the chat yeah we
definitely we got him we got him we're
gonna put the link in here awesome well
yeah definitely um so pretty much i kind
of made a book that looked at you know
the business and kind of different legal
aspects that related to the esports and
video game world so it kind of starts
laying the foundation
for what i call like the four major
parties of this business ecosystem so we
have the gaming talent which is the pro
gamers and the streamers you know the
people on twitch and youtube and tick
tock that are kind of creating gaming
content you have the coaches and the
analysts who are actually coaching these
players and then you have you know the
on-air talent the casters and the event
hosts that you're kind of talking about
that provide this color commentary and
the play-by-play and then we have the
teams and organizations and they
actually field the players so the face
clan the optic gaming 100 thieves team
liquid
cloud9
you know these organizations that have
been raising millions of dollars from
you know
prominent esports you know sports owners
and then you have the game developers
and publishers which i know you guys are
very much familiar with the activision
blizzard the riot games the val
you know ubisoft and you know epic games
so all these people that kind of own the
ip to the game and as a result they own
the game they kind of determine how it's
used all the different commercial
avenues and then you have the event
operators that actually run these
different tournaments and leagues you
know the kind of the stuff that you hear
about on twitch and you know the
evolution the evo series and all these
different things and then it starts to
look at different legal issues that
relates to the world so it's you know
copyright and trade market intellectual
property and visas and immigration
because this is a very international
world where you have players from all
over the world coming to the us to you
know join teams to compete in
tournaments here and they need to get
visas and you know business and llc
stuff and how you know as a streamer or
player you can you know protect yourself
with loan out companies and different
tax write-offs that might be valuable
and that are really just unique to this
area
and then what i would say is the most
you know
unique part is the contracts
chapter where i kind of go through
a sample major player agreement and
coach and caster and sponsorship
agreement and kind of explain the
different clauses and what they mean and
try to give you some negotiation tips of
stuff that might be important to look at
you know things that you that's kind of
what you're saying like a little bit of
insight into my head of kind of maybe
how i would approach
you know this kind of agreement and what
both sides because there's always two
sides to every situation every
negotiation there are certain things
that are more important to other people
that maybe are less important than you
it's always important to identify those
because maybe something that's really
important to them doesn't matter that
much to you
so you can give a point knowing that
something else is more important and
it's really important to kind of be able
to do that and then i kind of bring it
all together looking at you know the
growth of esports associations and
federations which are you know
international and you know you know
government bodies that are kind of
fostering esports and governing it and
trying to kind of create almost like the
olympics for esports you know they have
something called the the international
esports federation which you know i
think they have 110 member countries and
you know all a lot of different
countries the world all have their
esports national organizations as part
of it and it's meant to kind of
be this ioc for
you know esports i think it's uh
absolutely amazing uh
that this is able to happen because a
lot of times uh when you come from the
inner city or
any walk of life
you have the athletic and you have the
unathletic right and usually the
unathletic uh kids weren't able to make
a buck in
in what they chose to do so like if if a
kid has he's a savant in video games um
there's actually an avenue for him to
make a career at that a short career in
this uh genre
opposed to just get a basketball get a
football he's not athletic enough he's
not tall enough you know type of thing
it's not dedicated enough you know i
think that's the biggest that's the
heart a lot of hard work in this um
my question to you
uh do you see
esports
at some point in time
being on equal footing with athletic
sports
as far as revenue uh generated and
as reach and and global awareness oh
yeah i think that esports and i think
most people that are in a degree like
it's going to blow away because as you
say you know what's called the indoor
kids there's a lot more people that fit
into that bubble that fit into the six
foot five i can dunk or run a four sub
40.
and you know i think that you know i
kind of hear this buzz like the esports
bubble burst and
it's like i don't even think especially
in north america and the us i don't
think it's even started i think that
it's going to really grow with the kids
that are now you know 10 11 12 15 16 the
kids that have literally grown up
with digital everything like us like you
know you guys may be a little older but
it's like we had you know i went from
you know what was it from a vhs you know
you had the audio cassette discman
walkman
you had books like these kids have grown
up with digital music digital books
digital video games their whole entire
universe is digital like
i had stacks of dvds and the cd binder
like fragrance okay like we grew up in a
different universe but these kids you
know in five years from now when they're
finally at the 18 20 you know the
buzzword that they always throw with
esports
they're gonna like it's just naughty
it's not even gonna be a thing of like
oh like you're playing video games and
you don't tell people it's just gonna be
the same way
you go home and shoot basketball at the
parks the same way you're gonna go home
and play 2k and you know i think the
same way there's widow league there'll
be little league of legends and you know
everyone will you know in the morning
you'll play soccer in the afternoon
you'll play fifa league
and it'll just be the evolution
of
the rest of us you know there'll always
be this super high competitive scene
there'll always be people that want to
go pro in it but again most of us aren't
going to be that that level
that we're going to be able to but we
still want to play 2k like i play 2k
with some of these pro kids they are
phenomenal i think i'm pretty good at 2k
but once i play with them it's like wow
like there's another level oh yeah being
good at this game start playing with
someone like way better than you like am
i trash
well it's just it's just like they do
realize what the block button is for
now this is real man this is real i'm
glad you brought that up because i know
it's gamers you know sometimes we look
at it in our own little box and we don't
understand how things are trending you
know how this next generation of gamers
how this thing's influencing and like i
said with your book which is
tremendously put the link in the chat
please check it again because it's
really informative and it really is
giving out a lot of game as well as
professor you're doing podcasts you're
like you're all over educated man you're
doing your thing it's really cool
you know to to learn about this stuff
but um before we
need to bring protocol real quick all
right yeah that's something i know i
know what you
it's really crazy oh yeah he's dead
he said
oh he can't read the super chat now yeah
you don't want to read this super chat
oh that's what it is
erotic sports solve when are we getting
together to team up
and he put a joystick yeah
smiley heart eye guy
time but before he goes we gotta ask the
question that we ask all the members the
guests in the relics that's laughing i
mean
lord justin's top five video games or
franchises of all time
this was a tough one i mean i i
definitely you know i've mentioned a few
times starcraft and starcraft 2 is
probably
you know
and then you know madden and 2k he
always been a sports guy
okay and you know zelda ocarina of time
would still be one of those salute
i get you know mario kart is just one of
those games
and
you know
it's like super smash like i just feel
like you know i've never been like i've
never been good at first-person shooters
even going back to goldeneye i was trash
like halo trash
just using my bullets can't aim like
even in fortnite i'm the dude that drops
and then gets killed with my pickaxe
it's just like those are just not my
games ever so i always i really always
you know shifted from them and you know
then these larger games i just never had
time i feel like you know sports games
is always time i play with friends
always just something like doing you
know doing the franchises and you know
like getting all the rookies and young
people i thought were going to be sick
and just kind of like you know building
all like thinking about how you got to
build offensive lineman and d-backs
first and madden
because like you need to have a running
game you need to protect a quarterback
it's not just about having four good
wide receivers it's because like you
could have one sick one but the guys
that are fast and quick could run routes
good and you can make them better and
it's just like
that was always fire i used to do that
bro oh my god looking at those stats
pass blocks that the
release and the route run it and all
that yeah
you know and then like you know i would
say like when you're talking about games
like you know nhl 94 but then like i
would say madden 0-1 with that like
that l.a rams kurt warner marshall
isaac bruce tory hall like that was like
my favorite gaming time
is to like get into that shotgun and
it's just like over just right you know
as i zero hakeem ricky roll yeah
yeah you just can't exactly you just
couldn't could not he's that team yeah
that was those those are some errors man
that i remember the michael vick era
when he came oh and he broke the game he
got a little coin yeah that was already
a little like corny where you had oh for
michael van gaal 99. yeah we're
literally just he got out of the pocket
and it was just like either i'm gonna
sell out and maybe get him or he's just
going to throw it over my head yeah
that's actually a salute to you man
tremendous choices and the last question
we always ask favorite console of all
time and why
i guess that the most memories they have
is probably n64 it's probably that like
you know
playing you know nfl blitz nfl hit nhl
hits
like nfl street nba street like no no no
mercy no wrestling yeah exactly
mercy
like my guy the regulator how can i
forget that that might even be top five
no mercy
that was a game that we played for hours
my creative player guy was the regulator
the regular
your bed is gaming and obviously you
know mario tennis oh you know smash
brothers mario kart you can never go
wrong with mario kart ever whereas like
you know wayne gretzky hawk 3d hockey
yeah that was a great one classic and
[Music]
yeah he's talking about launch type that
launch title they launch titles was
crazy yeah they had did that wave race
would they have waitress at large
then obviously super mario 64. everyone
can just
you know of of course legendary stuff
man so i feel like that's probably the
you know console that's all
don't doubt the lord justify salute to
you brother absolute pleasure to have
you in the realm hearing your story
learning about esports again before you
go wicked and five people find you want
to learn more
plug your stuff man talk to the people
where they can find you well thank you
guys so much for having me this was
amazing and everyone for tuning in and
definitely follow me on twitter
justinjsq
that's definitely my you know dm's are
open so if you have any questions
definitely feel free to reach out i'm
always you know happy to talk to people
and
you know definitely get in touch with me
there no doubt put the twitter up in
there and again a tremendous book the
esport the essential guide to the
business and law of esports and
professional video game highly
recommended you can learn a lot about
what's going on and just on the
contractual level the legal side there's
a lot to it man please support the guy
again an absolute thank you for your
time i know we had you a little longer
than
we have problems but i appreciate you
taking the time and with also the
audience and you know we're gonna keep
building and talking again man much love
lord justin jacobson you already know
thank you guys it's a pleasure and i
look forward to our next conversation oh
you already know we you will be back all
right
no no justin absolute present man thank
you so much
so we got some super chats we got to
catch up we had a couple we got a couple
okay cool hold on one second okay so we
got
okay ace 23 became why 20 super chat
last quarter like for like data revenue
playstations minus two uh percent xbox
minus seven percent three and a half uh
times higher drop for xbox hardware
sales playstation is plus four point
four percent xbox is minus 11
15.4 percent swing in playstations favor
xbox not disclosing software sales
profit updated game pass or xbox live
gold numbers
i i don't i don't care about your fake
facts
oh my god wow
what we will address is we will adjust
this disrespectful super chat that you
send over here so we will address it
when the
financials actually talk about
financials
i live in north america so you about to
fall back
he made all this upking
i don't care about his his fake factions
shout out to sony for trying to put out
this propaganda like these still
relevant let's go
here we go
there we go hector the macho man five
dollars which i don't know if this is
that's all hector i'm not sure i'm not
sure if it is if it is what's up brother
this is the real macho man
to be honest i love esports because the
kids it it
it gives kids a chance to be a pro gamer
and gives them a chance to get paid for
their hard work and passion for games
that is true that is true
and they better have one hell of a
lawyer and you better
watch the back end because i think uh it
just reminds me of the child stars of
the 80s the 80s you better have like the
boy bands yeah have your paper but you
better holla at justin better holiday
you better holla at justin you're out
here excited 360 deals
in the korean shop
i can't believe you took all my money
king you gotta look at the chat uh once
once we get to uh free r kelly you got
it oh he's back oh
he's out well he's outside real
i'm gonna light you like a cigarette
you know i'm gonna tell you right now
you picked the wrong day
[Laughter]
you know what you know what's funny king
free archive come up here and he's like
you know what king you triggered my trap
card
[Laughter]
and what he
did was go play that yard instead of
worrying about trap cards
jesus leave what he won't kill him we're
gonna see what he got to say go play the
yo yo
amazing neil two dollars which had great
show my brothers thank you sir we have
amazing neil once again two dollar super
chat saw blue tea for anonymous should
be a large please so amazing neil i
don't have any control over that unless
i place the order for you yeah since you
went in if you got the wrong size you
have to go in and cancel the order and
then reorder i i can't access that stuff
shout out to him he put it down and make
sure y'all leave a comment we're seeing
it but on check out leave a comment so
we can see it when it comes up or
live
i don't know if you guys been noticing
in the chat i've been putting these
funny little i put the book back up to
need something to carry all your game
reformers in try it out
and take a picture with the merch so we
can hey put up on social media take a
picture of the trip yeah you already
know and we got flame two dollars up a
chat good afternoon fellas hope you all
have a great show thank you my brother
we have lucius augustus member for 12
months thank you sir
shout out to the iop and rest in peace
to bill russell an nba legend yeah he
just uh got announced that he passed
away this morning age of 88.
yeah recipes to the legend man it's a
long great life but yeah some of the
most championships
then we got jd gamer 20 super chat shout
out to the lords on the lord's day side
note question for the panel i assume
we've all seen the trailer for wakanda
forever the question is did you like it
and how are you feeling if it's better
than the first movie uh we talked about
this last week
uh yeah i don't know you can go back and
listen to our thoughts but you know i
love the first one so yeah first one
first movie is great this is going this
is going to be a challenge for them so
we'll see we'll see i'm going to take
addict's part on it you can trick us one
time you're not going to trick us twice
so uh attic is is very famous in saying
this you know with god of war they you
you switch stuff up and you got
everybody galvanized in this one spot i
don't think you can go back to the world
twice i don't think you have the same
reaction just gonna be a good movie yeah
that makes sense too it's hard to to
one-up something like that okay
well let me see we got something else i
know it's like okay we got
uh so free r kelly
right after sentencing
dang it's over so do you what he just
came hey he just just came outside of
your yard he got phone time
you can see him across the yard
he just got out of a solitary guy
you're gonna go right back to the box
season the prison break keep right back
in receipts
he said it's over for xbox
yeah yeah don't go don't don't lift no
weights in the yard
your camera keeps focusing on your mic
you might want to put your mic down just
a little bit
yeah it's it's it's way bring it down
yeah just bring it down just a hair so
it doesn't look like yeah let it poke
out yeah
all proximity
you know when king was telling me how to
do these i had to take one of kings oh
man
you know what's funny what if playing my
joystick is actually a woman
yeah that would that would kind of that
would be
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so you accept it dude
i know what you're saying you don't even
see you'll be even crazy or something if
that's really your wife yo what does she
got
she tried to check
she got a burner account
moving along
give me what say five dollars nothing
like sitting at my desk feet up and
listening to the lord i'm like the lord
the lord we're just the lord on my day
off and as always
hey king boo-boo
a4
[Laughter]
joystick is upsetting attic for pointing
out songs
[Laughter]
enough of the foolery let's get to the
third topic gentlemen we now know why
jim ryan is following the xbox model
because sony guys don't buy games
oh man
here we go
then we got hollywood rules two thousand
chat condolences lord sob respect bro
i appreciate that brown i really
appreciate it thank you
um then we have hector macho man two
dollar super chat kids don't sign to
death row
hashtag no 360 deals yeah there you go
do not do that all right then we have
let me see i know we jumped a little bit
let me go back yeah
and we got hollywood rules again five
dollars for chat another fantastic iop
sunday with my four boys great job last
night king
let let me he's laughing at it you said
let it poke out wow also
them some game sale numbers jim's still
saying y'all not enough oh yeah they're
talking first i tell dude these fake
metrics that they won't throw
a quick question for the chat um me and
king are going to do a lot more
community nights uh obviously uh you
know solve and cog if they're able to
make it they'll be there but i i want i
want input from the community what
community games you think would be fun
for all of us to play obviously there's
games that you know
only us four are going to play but me
and king want to incorporate more of you
know the community in general but we
need more games uh such as like fall
guys i know you can have lobbies in that
uh gta 5's one i don't know if i really
trust some of you guys in gta 5. yeah
well i'm going to play pub g i want to
play i want to shoot some of these dudes
like i want to see r kelly running
across the yard
do they let playstations in jail
well they don't allow crossplay so go
buy xbox all right
let me
let me read this last one real quick
cause the microwave is coming on do
y'all think that sony's latest security
briefs might hinder their online service
uh services subscriber numbers thoughts
this this is from stitch 33 months thank
you do we think what i don't even catch
it oh do we think that they were
hamburger oh do you think that sodas
letting security breach by hitting their
their online surface success i didn't
even realize about that security
security breach
wait a second what do you think was
gonna happen when they just put up a
service and don't change the service
like
you know like what do you think they
still have calvin watching the door
letting the same people in
with the same old shenanigans calvin
like oh yeah don't pat him down he cool
that's the same dude that robbed the
place
full time you dudes really think you
have to care so y'all thought that y'all
was gonna get a service and you was
gonna be safe no you just put a banner
up to let more criminals in calvin don't
care he letting the whole king's bridge
in
queens really just outside
run around yo
i don't even hear about the uh the
breach how long ago did it happen i
didn't even know about it um it was just
the uh
the thing that just recently happened
yeah just just recently it was the food
that went in there oh and instead of
instead of stealing stuff he went in
there inflated their numbers
anyway
he said he said i ain't gonna say no
more pics what i'm gonna do is i gotta
get in there and physically work the
numbers myself
okay
this guy right here definitely with his
first hand accounts are how it goes down
imagine imagine king trying to like
social net engineer like he'll walk up
he'll be sitting there
king will be in like the the the the the
outfit that you're supposed to go on
there and be like a
tech for an ip tech for something like i
need to check the sword into the name
fake stress testing
yeah well there's no stress that's just
two people in the went down paul got
that xbox necklace on and they're like
yo we don't allow that here are you
discriminating
that right here everybody take a picture
turn my camera on my chest camera hey
record this guy
bessie anyway we go with the super chat
stuff yeah
we are caught up right now back
microwave real quick we got kate no is
it for me yeah
so no so the plane the plane is my ac
you you guys are just getting normalized
to the sound of it so i guess when i
unmute you just hear it like boom
[Music]
okay
i forgot uh paul real quick last week
pro results are in the people spoken to
the question with the recent controversy
regarding the last of us one remake
leaks and price point which opinion do
you align with the most the winner of a
close three-way ilp poll at 41 of the
vote was game company should be called
out for charging full price on a game
remastered multiple times in a short
time frame the changes are not
substantial enough to warrant 70 dollars
group coming in at second at 33 percent
was the messy lords i don't care because
when it's the game you love you gonna
bend the knee anyway
and then last place at uh 25 of the vote
was the market dictates the value of the
game gamers should be allowed to be
excited for a rematch a remake or
remaster without being chastised shout
out to all the lords who participated
lord addict the realm agrees with you
but it was close it was close you know
what you feel they saying that um they
don't feel it's worth the 70.
it's not worth it
[Music]
so you i don't i don't yeah i agree
obviously you know i want to point out
that uh
even if the realm disagrees with me i'm
i'm still right so you know it is what
it is if they disagree i must say i'm
right if they agreed i'm gonna really
say i'm right so you know shout out to
the realm for for for knowing where
for knowing where
right there you already know i heard
some super chats or something going on
membership's going off something's going
on yeah it was membership like i have to
screen have to chat
let's get as many as that chat green man
people people people get up that member
so let's get that green in that chat man
put some logos in that chat too we got
five new
realm members man i want to see some
logos i want to see some some crest in
that chat get some crest in that chat
yeah man so i am up
first
uh ea yeah man black panther games shout
out to jeff grubby grub
giant by venture beating all that and um
games be excuse me and uh gay his show
game mess morning so yeah it looks like
electronic quick yes sorry so you said
addict's world sounds like a
dictatorship it is
shout out
shout out to jeff grove again on the gay
mess yeah ea's getting into a superhero
game looks like they are going to the
titles early in development for the
black panther game it's a single-player
affair new seattle studio founded by
former monolith productions vp and
studio head kevin stevens is likely
working on the project starting with the
death of one black panther players take
with a character that is becoming the
newest incarnation of the wakandan hero
and then we got take a little bit more
details uh not too much more but um yeah
so pretty much a development title is
project rainer um i talk about who was
developing it and again single player
and stuff like that so wanted to bring
this to the realm this was a big one a
lot of people were excited some people
you know maybe concerned attic me you
had some conversations offline about it
so let's start with you man ea black
panther gate
what you feeling
i think they they do have some people
over there that made um the lord of the
ring games from wb so that that's
that's very appealing because i really
enjoy that that engine well well not the
engine though just the game in general
it's a shame they couldn't get the
nemesis engine as well uh you know i i
still don't understand why
the government let them copyright that
engine it's still to this day it just
mind bothers me but you know we'll see
you know there are some talent over
there i do feel like what made that uh
you know shadow of war shadow of mordor
uh such relevant games was that nemesis
so we're gonna have to see how
they incorporate black panther uh but
the good thing is i have a lot of faith
and um
man i forgot his name
i know um
i have a lot of faith in
the dude that respawned what do you talk
about
okay you talking about me what's your
man's
manage that at least to the point where
they'll give
that studio whatever the name is going
to be the same privileges that he had
making you know uh fallen order because
my no
what is it yeah
uh so i just i just hope it's a good
game because i do think that you know
people automatically go off of its ea i
would have been a hundred percent with
you guys
before
fallen order
i'm like nah they they've got they've
got like you're good you're good yeah
but after falling order now i'm gonna
say like i was here before following
order about the making a marvel game but
now i'm like here you know by 25 you
know 75 they mess it up 25 they do but
if vince is in charge it's like a here
well we don't know if vince is in charge
we just know that but i know he's over a
lot of studios now
he's elevated over there if he's
influencing it in any sort of way okay
fair enough lord soft we had a big
discussion you know about wakanda
forever trailer that bust out into an
mcu
podcast that the realm clearly loved
which was interesting so i figured this
would be a good
uh you know topic to kind of bring back
right on time right right lord talked
about it first so what did you feel when
you heard ea
black pant the game in development i
mean first we also kind of had a little
bit of this conversation about the value
of monolith outside of other wb
properties we did have this on the front
of the people
ultimate and how you know the guys at
those studios whether it's
as a collective monolith or just them
individually they have the chops to make
third-person action games so for me
anybody that's associated with that type
with that studio or wb montreal or uh uh
what's up call it um
the studio making suicide squad
rocksteady um those guys know how to
make their person action game so
immediately the first thing i heard when
i heard ea was like oh no yeah
attic was bombing me he was just like oh
but then when i heard that it was a new
studio
and you know and honestly it's one of
those things that's an immediate
reaction
yeah no because i'm i have my niece and
my nephew here and somebody doesn't seem
to understand the meaning of mute yeah
so i've had
exactly so um
give me one more now do your business
we'll come back so i've got to handle
something
so look man we had the big discussion
and uh you had a lot of thoughts you
know about the wakanda forever you know
trailer now that you hear ea black
panther game the the player beco is
becoming the new black panther
in line with the old black panther
potentially dying so um
yeah what are your cake
face i don't like face apparently
you get it well real quick before you
guys apparently like the leaks was like
uh you're supposed to be like a resident
that is building your way up to be black
or something like that yeah
because ac is crazy yeah we disputed
that he good everybody's happy that the
discipline was in order everybody's
happy daddy songs
daddy's stuff is bad i'm glad i'm glad
to have them with me but you know it's
one of the things like hello i told you
so um yeah so going back to it like
again initially my reaction to the ea
was like oh man but then hearing about
you know the new studio led by monolith
leads um the fact that you know
to be quite honest
after they gave vin zampeller more power
after they seen what respawn was able to
do with fallen order and what we hope
they do with jedi survivor
um
i have a little more confidence in what
they could do with a third-person action
game i feel that they do believe in the
importance of of single-player uh games
again right don't want to go down that
route again so i'm excited for it to be
perfectly honest i'm excited for what
they can do
yeah you know let's recapture some of
that old ea mojo like they don't haven't
had that in a long time and i would love
to see them come out and with an amazing
open world black panther game
that is you know again
it's one of those things when you think
about
the locomotion or what did you say
did you see attic
punish me like that yo
wow yo i show you
twenty dollar for him
he's trying to silence you we just wanna
let you know we see we see where you are
oh my god continue
it's so um
the chocolate that came out yeah it did
yeah
so
i'm excited for this i i do think
hopefully this team being put together
has what it takes to do this i the
leadership obviously does has experience
in that so i'm happy about that um the
question is what kind of game do they
make because they're talking about an
open world game when you talk about
black panther his skill set like you you
need to think about the locomotion right
you need to think about how it gets
around if you think about locomotion in
spider-man you think about what you
assume they're gonna do with wolverine
on the insomniac side right mainly
character because you know exactly
there's a lot of melee um he has a lot
of stuff where his his suit absorbs
energy and he he pushes that back out
pause so
you know and also story-wise i really do
hope that this is a t'challa game i i
really do hope that
they said it is a new black panther i'm
hoping i do not
i can understand the premise of like you
are the black panther so you want to
chopper
you want to chalk his death i want i
wanted to beat to chaka's death however
they they they sort of engulfed that
whatever story they won't want to build
around the chocolate's death and
t'challa takes over civil war
yeah i don't want this
yeah i want something of that nature
like give me a t'challa story i don't
understand this sort of othering of
t'challa like
big
i would actually be disappointed if that
is the case where it's just like this
blank slate black panther i actually
think it would be cool to like build a
character to like earn the right
speaking of build character
i know i got a kid here we go
that that is also a very controversial
subject those special media if if
they're people some people were
concerned
by the verbiage of
the single player game where the player
becomes the new black panther some
people were concerned that there would
be a character creator and then there
was other concern
about white characters
about the ethnicity we make no sense oh
if it were a lot like a skyrim level
created which is which is why i don't
think it is unless
it's gonna be really bad if there's a
character developer you can make a light
like you know and again i
i don't even want to i don't want to
even comment on this subject i do not
want to comment on the subject
it is a concern
yeah exactly please take that decision
out of our hands and make it a t'challa
game and that's it like let's just
do that but again in fairness i'm joking
in fairness i see slovo in a chat well
let me let me
let me let me shout out my man grubby
grub lord jeff grub
he said cause this came up and again he
got the time to connect he was like no
he's like for what he's hearing there's
no character you would not be able to
make another ethnicity black panther but
i thought it was funny that there was a
lot of vitriol and concern
that this could happen in a black venue
but according to grump just for the
record i know i'm joking the clown you
from what we hear now you cannot do that
we assume the ethnicity will be another
african character
no way that they would do that right
like the the amount
of
heat they would give i couldn't even
describe no but but again you know i
understand where the conversation comes
from solve just think about it this way
you scared to talk about it they did it
i understand where the combo comes from
right because the same thing happened
with with the gta leaks right and they
were like what do you mean they're not
going to be you know as edgy anymore
what do you really like you just never
know
what the thinking is at the highest
levels of that so that's the way that's
the ea feeling
exactly it's that thing of like well i
don't want to offend anybody if you
don't want to offend anybody just make
sure that
that character creator doesn't go too
well that's all fair enough i am dying
to hear your thoughts on this based on
the uh wakanda you know trailer forever
trailer and then now this news ea black
panther game where do you stand on this
how do you feel well i um
i'm i'm kind of kind of over the whole
uh disney bastardizing black panther
um
to the
extent that
uh
we are caught up with an actor that
played the role who passed away talking
about it talk about it you're talking
about a fictional character that can
never die
right so there's no vaulting away
something could that can never die
all right there's presidents uh that's
in front of you
had that same energy with christopher
reed
did you have that
did you have that same energy with
christopher reeve how many iterations of
superman do we need to have when they
continued that universe that same
universe with another superman
that was they do it with uh batman they
do it with every character
known the man
but here we go with this i did not talk
when nobody was talking
all right so we we
did this part right here and we got
we're not voting this character off like
this this this one specific character
because it was so successful there's a
political agenda around this whole thing
to be honest with you and i'm seeing it
and it's making me sick right uh the
movie was powerful good it reached
everybody and it made an awareness that
awareness scared the hell out of a lot
of people so okay now
you you want to automatically attach
chadwick boseman to t'challa like he he
was not the living embodiment of
t'challa he was he was just a great
actor
all right so we're not going to do that
and and it nauseates me i don't want
ea to do uh
mcu black panther i don't want it
because that means that you got to
follow these stupid guidelines that are
set into place and try to keep up with
what their story line is as far as the
child of passing away there's billions
of stories that you can tell from the
black panther inside the books that has
absolutely nothing to do with the mcu
which i think that black panther is a
better character than the character
that's inside the mcu
right i thought that character was timid
i thought that character wasn't bold
enough i thought that character wasn't
exactly who the black panther was in the
books
but you you have an inclusive all for
one black panther and
killmonger's thought process was more in
line with the radical nature of black
panther
at that period of time right so
really if you really like the black
panther you should love killmonger
because his mentality was that of that
but also
keeping wakanda
secluded away because of the technology
anyway
i don't care about that i it's about ea
right that's my question i don't trust
them
i don't they don't and everybody keeps
on bringing a fallen order but you it
was it was broken in certain spots in
the beginning there's nothing really
fluid with certain things in the game
was amazing
all right
i just
i beg to differ right it's a it's a
really good game it's a really good at
least it's good okay
no no i didn't say it was trash oh okay
i was like
but if if we're doing superhero games
and my top superhero game is spider-man
2018
and we're talking about that then
i want that level of care
i want that level of storytelling i want
that level of transition seamlessly
from action to to to storytelling to the
panels so do has ea show me they can do
that
no they haven't
so when when
i see the game i'm a reserve judgment
until i see the game because obviously
they're doing the game um but again i
don't want them nowhere near it to be
honest with you uh i would i would pick
a whole ton of other people to do it and
when they said ea was coming out with
the game i'm like oh no hell not even
monolith not even
um no the shadow of border guys no no
shadow mortals is cool
you know um
attic talks more about the nemesis
engine than actually the game
well i mean i like the game with the
nemesis engine is definitely what made
it see
is the nemesis engine is actually the
catalyst for him to really be attached
to segments if you take the name
assistant out of the game
i don't even know how they would have
made the game you see
so again
i don't trust those dudes and ea i guess
i'm so uh so soured on ea products no
girl that's fair
i don't know how they're gonna mess it
up ea will always
have the opportunity to give you a slam
dunk
and they will always finger roll it okay
so you're looking at like stuff like ed
you look at that right i want to get
before i go addict wanted to get some
balls also added
yeah i mean when it comes down to it i
definitely agree with you uh
you know especially the the disney uh
takes like you know i do feel like you
know because i'm kind of like in the
middle with that
because part of me is like you know
i don't think they want to to annoy half
a twitter because i because just about
as many people as i say to recast them i
see just as many people saying not to
recast them and then when you come to
the ea faction it's like
i don't know if that's gonna be part of
the disney stuff because i personally
feel like
if that was the case they would probably
have insomniac make it because it seems
like that is going to be their like game
cinematic universe
so uh you know i don't know if they're
going to be connected in any way but i
do feel like i'm with you with ea i
don't think he has done enough to prove
themselves
in terms of single player thing but well
i will say he's like fall in order to me
gave me enough faith that there is a
shot and hope but they can't do it as
far as how they do it as far as who they
let do it and you said like you know a
different studio i couldn't really tell
you another studio besides wrong steady
which is making something else besides
insomniac which is making two games and
besides this studio which we don't even
know them because they're a new studio
that's all but this is the thing this is
another thing that grew up speculated
was the fact that there's probably
another game for marvel in the works at
ea so he's speculating that the same
they might have the same type of deal
with ea that they initially had with
square enix
so we could definitely see more coming
from them so again the black panther
would be the test bed to see exactly
what the heck's going on you know what
they can do or can't do but i i do think
there is more than one in the works
right and it can destroy everything in
one one
if insomnia makes their own
universe in the in the gaming scene with
marvel and 2k makes i mean and ea makes
their own so it's just like that's crazy
if you think about it two cinematic
universes in gaming off of marvel by two
different companies yeah little look i
mean this is a it's a fun discussion i i
thought i want to comment some stuff in
the chat between uh shady and slow-mo
too because they actually have some
interesting points i want to touch on
but look you know i'm kind of definitely
addict on this one only because kate i
understand your concern you know saying
like i'm not going to minimize that ea's
history is not
the greatest over the last couple years
in reference to you know
it's been more of a monetization track
and regurgitating
you know whether it be the the fifa and
the um you know the maddens and stuff
like that
and not really truly iterating i think
for me
you know
i'm confident two reasons one where
addicts said
i know vince is not developing this game
he doesn't say i know he's not but
his influence to me means a lot because
the jedi fallen order
is really revered by a lot of people
because everyone thought okay single
player start they're gonna mess this up
and let's be honest we didn't think they
would get a single player star wars type
game with a narrative focus because we
like okay where's the micro transactions
at where's the things that they do
where's the multiplayer oh what's that
other one battlefront or whatever
right like multiplayer only they're
going to figure out a way to monetize it
and churning out and not respect the
history so when we see
vince get there they have success
doing it the traditional way right
then it's like okay let's elevate him
because we didn't expect that to to to
go and another thing i think we don't
really not give enough credit is even
though he doesn't make technically
single-player games jose ferris
right because you look at it takes two
it looked like a no way out even though
they're co-op they're they really single
player kind of story based games but
you're playing it with a friend he's in
there he's involving that friend and i
think what they're seeing is yo we can
do these games and still win right we
can do these now where i'm with you king
is
from you know the lord better than me i
never challenge your law or mcu marvel
characters you have all these books you
know every nuance every detail
the thing that bothers me
is
the storyline
appears to be mirroring what's going on
in wakanda forever right and that's
where me and you are 100 aligned because
there's a part of me that's like
why we have to kill black panther off to
start off with a new story right and
again i'm not trying to make this a
complete racial thing it just
i have a sensitivity towards it you know
i'm saying that that's just i'm going to
be honest right that's just i just look
at it like damn like okay our character
has to have this okay fine we have the
character but
my thing is we could tell it to child a
story like the child is amazing
character right now the thing i do want
to touch on in the chat and again shout
out slow mom and shady i'm not trying to
call y'all out specifically i just feel
y'all having an interesting debate which
was about the you know and i mean you
talk about this number of times we talk
about everything about quote unquote
race
in video games and stuff like that right
and i do think slo-mo does make a
fantastic point where the the actual
origin of the characters is wholly based
on where they're from
and the ethnicity so thus you know he
made an example of like you are we going
to have another
race of shang
she if he comes out you see what i'm
saying because
exactly the whole character's origin is
based on
their ethnicity their racism is
everybody wanted iron right and uh uh of
asian descent right
and that that's why i in this case cause
i understand people like yo but race
swap all the time why the problem with
black panther if there's a character
created that's the point that i think
people are trying to say in that regard
and to be honest i'm just having fun
i'll just make silly so please don't
take it that's the thing i just thought
it was funny no because you know that's
a serious concern yeah and your
seriousness
your silliness in every joke uh every
the truth is ten percent that is uh
serious
yeah that's a concern if they would ever
dream of that putting a character
creator that you can actually make
characters of different
hell no not that character and you're
not gonna do that you can't because it
doesn't make any sense
all right oh he was a light-skinned dude
in in in in the heart of africa with his
son beating down on his back
we're not gonna do that we're not going
to do
a black shank
we're not going to do that we're not
going to do a black iron fist we're not
going to do that and and
what i'm seeing with disney
what they're having so much liberty with
i mean i love the hell out of disney
right but i'm seeing a lot of stuff like
what they did with my internals that
fast dude they turned they they gender
swapped them right right and the uh
what's the other one i forgot the other
one yeah exactly the ancient one the
ancient one from doctor strange
oh yeah that's right so so it's it's
certain things that you grew up with
and you make concessions i've been
making concessions with disney
for a very long
time just for inclusion's sake
i'm not making no concessions on this
one bro
i'm not going to sit there and take a
step back because i will stand up and i
will fight for shanghai if you try that
with him i will stand up and fight with
black panther if you try it out with
that
this is just certain things that we're
gonna keep it a buck with and we're not
gonna play that game with it and you say
it as a joke but i know in the meeting
when when these dudes don't play games
and they don't care about no comic books
they said listen
we want everybody to enjoy this we don't
want to segment it off to one uh race of
people because that that doesn't make
money right
at the bottom line when is the integrity
of that actual character that stan lee
made that he died for right shot and you
know
you know jack kirby and these guys they
worked so hard to weave this lore into
these characters and they stood up at a
time when it wasn't cool that was
knocking all right that was at that time
popular then yeah you're right so to do
that and to to change that right there
hell no i'm gonna take a stance on that
i would not support it i would not do i
would not talk about it
if that was to be the thing that added
you won't get your balls off them before
i think
race walking is only acceptable
when the character itself
even if you made them white black asian
it doesn't matter it's not going to
change anything in the actual lore of
anything like you know uh albert wesker
a lot of people got mad because they uh
they made him black but it's just like
sure there's little things that would
change but like it's not drastic like
because there's certain things people
only like take as the initial character
but then you got to take it as you got
to switch most likely got to change
their kids a different color it's like
you know
albert wesker i felt like if he was
black it wouldn't really drastically
change anything like
sure some things might have to be
changed but it's not something like like
black panther like his entire origins is
revolved around african culture
how do you realistically change that in
any way shape or form without changing
the entire entity of the character yeah
it's like it's like the equivalent of um
changing what's that character which one
that was in captain america the
the character that was racist he fought
him in the first one
he would be the red skull
like to change him to a different color
like his entire origins is off him being
german
yeah let me let me jump to super chat so
we can there's a one that addresses this
um we got tai chi soros 15 to chat if
there can be a black spider man miles
which i like a lot that can be a white
panther but in the first game of black
panther it should be t'challa have an
amazing day lords i i respect the
opinion but i disagree wholeheartedly
for what addict just said there's
nothing origins of that origins that
determines his color his color
whatsoever the whole point of spider-man
is that it can be anyone it literally
can be anyone that's not peter parker
though but it's not peter parker right
right you got miles more they literally
made a whole different person mm-hmm to
become uh spider-man the inclusion
spider-man all right don't don't mess
with my peter parker bro if i woke up
tomorrow and my peter parker was black i
will i will have a problem right i like
my peter parker exactly from queens i
like my white peter parker from queens i
love him and and don't don't do that if
they make miles is miles that's cool
hispanic and black that's cool but but
peter parker coming to my to my
knowledge because i'm not 100 up on
comic books general comic books to my
knowledge the only way you you can even
eat the fruit i think that's how you
become black panther you can eat the
fruit and the only way that like the
powers is bestowed upon you was the
ancestors have to approve of you
so it's just like how does it make sense
a white dude going there and that entire
culture is different they're like
how'd you get here
exactly because you you look at the mcu
movies right and you look you can see a
scenario where the movie would be like
well something happens you know the
t'challa's not there nobody's there to
take up the mantle sherry doesn't want
to take up the mantle oh uh winter
soldier will take up the manchester but
then it would make no sense to take up
the mantle like if i could see something
like that happening it would make no
sense to why the ancestors would approve
of that to let him take up that mantle
right it should it be it shouldn't be
i'm just saying the people that in in
charge there are you when you look at
the scenarios created in these stories
you can see a scenario where somebody's
like yeah we could do this and get away
with it it's fine and no it's not fine
just i would just say it just it's i
just wanted the bread i didn't want to
make this right but i did feel that we
had to talk about it because you know
i'm a person that does like to listen to
the other side and there are there's a
contingent that feels like you know some
of their favorite character what's the
concern um what's the terminology woke
right so they'll be like yo you know
now they just woke and they turned
changed uh a caucasian or white
character into another race or another
um you know gender and i just wanted to
have that discussion because it
pertained to this
only because the character creative
thing came up as um something that you
know people were worried about with a
black panther game and i've seen grubb
get ahead of it so again normally you
know god don't really have any type of
discussions political stuff yeah but it
pertained to video games and i felt we
did need to talk about it i don't want
to set off a powder kick with everybody
but i had to feel like we had to talk
about it not to mention
like the bad like we'd only talk about
you know
if they incorporated it if they did
it would be so much racial stuff that
would go on the internet people would
put a white black panther up it would be
took him so less it's just like let's
just avoid all of that we don't need
that on the internet right now it's a
good discussion i'm glad we had we had
salute to the chat for mostly being
respectful with each other and thank
y'all you know
aggravated to a level that you have no
idea
my wife just texted me and said you
sound absolutely annoyed i am
i think i'm boy
the only thing that i would be okay with
that they did have a character creation
is that you you couldn't be white but
like people keep saying like if they did
something like the like something
similar to i don't know king you're
gonna have to have five shades of dark
skin
i'm the one that skips off the window
when i drive you're gonna have to have
this dog skin arm that stays inside
you're gonna have to have this dogs in
one right here that's not directly in
the sun no you're gonna have to have
this dog skin one with a sun hit down on
the top of it not even
five shades of dark skin and that's the
only dark skins you're gonna have five
shades of dawson so that's the only
character creator you gonna get and it's
gonna be five shades of king that's it
oh my god i've been talking about i'm
talking about in terms of how the story
goes because i saw the chat saying that
like you have to be a certain like
person to be able to even like
to my knowledge and that's all i'm gonna
go off the movies i don't know how much
they took off the movies you just have
to get nominated by tribe right to to
fight the king for his powers how does
that working like
if they were going that day they they
they really bastardized that whole
thought process well that's what i'm
saying i only know i i'm i'm casual i'm
casual
okay so what we're gonna do we're gonna
stay we're gonna stay in to casual realm
right they did have a fight for the
mantle of leadership right so i'm saying
they they're probably saying the
rational thought to it is how can
uh this guy get put in to the tribe
right first of all those uh four or five
tribes that are there in wakanda
are all of african descent right so
that probably cannot happen let's say um
the winter soldier did mate with
somebody of a high statute there and he
did form a child
now that child can grow and he can be
mixed and he can actually be part of
that tribe and that can happen i just
gave you a scenario if i'm writing a
book on how that can actually happen
all right so uh but again he asked and
he remember he was accepted as the white
wolf inside their whole tribal uh
scenario so if he was allowed to marry a
woman of wakandan descent and they did
have a child then that child can be born
into that and he can extend and grow up
to the to become the leader of said
tribe and that can definitely happen i
gave give a scenario the logical
blueprint of that happening anything
outside of that i don't believe that can
happen that way okay but they gave you
the out in doing so but this again i
said i'm i'm not for
that and i don't want
i'm about
protecting the integrity of the
characters
right to hell with anything else
i'm and and this is the old fuddy dirty
get off my lawn
i'm that dude
all right i'm i'm completely that dude
right so when i'm reading books i don't
i don't see color certain things because
thanos is purple right this is what i
grew up with but i also grew up with
peter parker being from queens and i
identified with his story because of x y
and z i identify with uh black panther
because of certain things so
when i'm talking i'm talking from a base
of marvel universe
before disney before all this other
stuff that was going on there you've
been controlling you've been consistent
all the board doesn't matter what race
you've been consistent i'll give you
that there's this just don't change up
my character's life let's get it we
gotta move on yeah i just wanted to
point out i wasn't even referring to the
tribes being white or anything like that
yeah no i know but i mean i gave you a
good one
good thing can happen like where you
spawn as a as a random person and like
one of the tribes and you work your way
up one of the tribes and then you can
slowly get your way to to have your
tribe recognize you as that person that
can be nominated i think they could go
that direction like the thing is i don't
think if they wanted to make a black
panther didn't have to trial is like the
main character i could see them doing it
they did it the right way hold on i
wanna i wanna i'm sorry i just wanna
address something because i see people
attacking shady right listen
we can all have opinions and disagree
let's just be respectful one thing about
us is even if it's an opinion we
disagree with we allow it to be her so
please lay off shady we just wanted to
have a discussion because it's an
important discussion right it's
important and we could have this we
could all be people and have a nice
intellectual discussion we ain't got to
attack each other or call anybody just
let's be respectful that's all i want to
say so so let's round it out finishing
it out i'm going to uh break protocol
again and bring one more from slo-mo
because i think this break this brings
in another conversation that has been
happening right
uh hold on a second slow-mo back slab
five dollar super chat i don't even like
the making name or some kind of aztec
warrior why are they uh bowing down to
dc aquaman when neymar predates aquaman
so this goes to the store the the story
now that um so neymar
in wakanda forever will not be
uh from atlantis
the kingdom is called talakan right so
the origins of neymar in that regard are
going to be changed and they're going to
be more reminiscent of again in terms of
look in terms of like the the history
and the lore they're gonna build around
it is more about aztec warriors so yeah
i'll i'll defer the king on this i can
tell you why um when uh wb trademarked
uh aquaman
uh marvel
was going through this whole thing with
neymar remember namor was owned by
different companies when they were
selling off different stuff so they
weren't able to get the rights to him
until now and they got the rights to him
now right but that had already passed
where
aquaman
is
atlantean right
aquaman they trademarked that whole
thing so marvel has to do a workaround i
do like the fact that it's an aztec inca
style
because what you have to look at what
was the original tribes that you were
looking at that period of time that
either washed off the face of the earth
right and you can say the incas washed
off for the face of earth where did they
go they could have went to the sea right
so you can tell that story from that
aspect um
if if it's a a copyright thing and it's
something like that but you still have
to get the story told
the story is being told in that way
because this is no other way other than
to tell it right so again this is disney
uh working with what they have available
yeah right it's not really changing up
the story for the character sake it's
trademarks that they can't use gotcha
you cannot be atlantean oh okay i didn't
know that okay cool cool so we good
thank y'all chad for being respectful
and clean up
and down the double we're gonna get
these super chats before we move on
there okay let's do it hold on let's say
we got some funny
black panther three starring vanilla ice
they already got a pocket
without a pocket
then we got a weedable five dollars of a
chap i can't wait for that creative
character because i'm making a horizon
forbidden panther ridiculous
then we got stitch 5.2 chad i hate you
stitch
from let me play with your joystick
which song would punish me like that
sorry i had to do it pause
i said i only see color and stitch make
sure that happens yeah he makes sure
he's gonna read that
then we got some flat difference five
dollars in the chat lord sob let's not
beat the kids up on the podcast player
you might saw your reputation with the
person that want to play with your
joysticks
there was no there were no beatings
going on i just wanted to bro
i know look you already know you got to
be careful you know why i gave him the
look because when he walked over and he
immediately sat down he wasn't you know
he wasn't paying attention to the
scenario around him so i looked at him
like hey you can't let's turn that off
yeah and he was like yeah whatever oh
and kept going so that's why yeah that
when i see that
[Laughter]
it goes like this wait a second
you ain't did the camera come on
one moment one more
time
there we go yeah baby farva once again
five dollars a chat they we told
batman's origin story like five times
lots of quality black male actors can
step into the role of black panther that
is true yep yep ty casars once again the
bronx walling out to the police out here
in the streets um tayyip casares 50 oh
we read that one okay and we got yay
baby father five dollars
okay white culture co-opted the word
woke that we've been using for ages and
made it something negative it's not
respectfully i i wouldn't say it's white
culture it's just it's the way the world
right now
people don't know and then i want to
point out that i see people in the chat
calling shady a racist and stuff like he
is not he's in my dm's that is a friend
of mine so stop bothering them we we
gotta have we got to start with this the
moment anything is done on the opposite
thing you are real automatically right
yeah because then at that point
both parties don't want to talk anymore
exactly okay i had a conversation once
the name calling happened there's
nothing about it i can
me and him talk all the time all right
so if uh shady was a racist he wouldn't
be bothering with the blackest dude that
you can see on this panel
generally often may i hide you i get
called a racist generally often just for
having any kind of opinion nothing that
is being being white
and being caught a racist is like the
most disrespectful thing you can do like
i know i know it hurts because me and
addict talk all night so he ain't
calling me at night yeah especially
people for the culture you know what i'm
saying it's like absolutely yeah don't
don't do it yeah we we need to stop
being so damn outraged by
by these words sometimes and and stop
and think for a moment what you're
saying but what i say is like i
respectfully disagree yeah exactly
i don't feel that opinion and that's it
they keep it moving that's it
uh let me see that we got jeez two
dollars super chat can i be mexican or
dominican at least
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
always mispronouncing
move on please
[Laughter]
should be robert downey jr lincoln
osiris
thunder it's a win-win so he must keep
lincoln's voice as black friends
yo robert downey jr black face
oh my god
thank you so much you got this pain left
the whole oh oh my god this chat is
hilarious
you know we got some foolishness in this
chat today
let me see let me see if we roll back a
little bit
okay we got the old bottle filled today
we got flame 2000 chat well anyways
hashtag free joystick hashtag read
themselves i'm going to talk about it
all right
stop silencing himself listen i paid
good money
i can't help it my mic stops working
sometimes
that's what it is he has technical
difficulties on specific super chat then
we have masochista five dollar super
chat which means masochists for the you
know who don't uh speak spanish
i'm all for not race swapping anyone
y'all want a white black panther just
make white cheetah just make something
new instead otherwise cash crap
just leave that whole wakanda like
because in order to make a white black
panther you have to
somewhere incorporate lore with white
people going into to wakanda just leave
that whole thing alone
with the winter soldier and that's my
only way for y'all to get in um
i showed you because they accepted him
into the tribe
they did what is it uh yeah then we got
tai kisara is three dollars which
happened there's a multiverse so donald
trump panther oh
[Music]
hold on
yeah i couldn't wait for this next
episode
that was hilarious man people should do
some super chats in purely spanish so i
can hear uh saul say something yeah
everybody was ready
in spanish
spartan gold seventeen two pounds super
chat cash slim shady as black panther
bro yo
you gonna have bars like that that boss
baby yeah
dance off and you're gonna wrap up okay
the closest thing a white dude will ever
be to black pants
yeah we've got pragmatic eagle five
dollars
this is why iop has no equal we'll never
find the laughs so hard outside of a
comedy club and also you four gents keep
it respectful thank you that means
that's what chat means the world thank
you thank you so much brother and then
we got not jack five dollar super chat
thank you brother and then yay baby five
bucks barbara
chat time
yeah time it was loose
all right this is kids topic y'all
hold on let me let me just sit back step
back you don't understand notice that we
never say and never mind let's just go
let that we never say somebody's talking
but we have to we just a new thing at it
we have to say
seem to always just listen to the
podcast right when kings yeah and they'd
be like all of them have bias all of
them
is he said rdx and then king yeah
he didn't even say
the king
yeah he said king damn
man i gotta do it again man king comes
in here every day
and looks at the playstation family the
moment they say sub
you triggered my trap card
that's what he do
all right you just see like the old the
old yu-gi-oh shows where the card pops
up and there's a key a picture key like
that yeah what the heck don't do that
for me man put king on the yu-gi-oh card
put it on twitter tag
your face
all right so here we are so microsoft
and sony financial job this week but
lord king definitely wanted to focus on
uh sanchez
novella oh i'm saying that you know xbox
series exodus has outsold the
playstation 5 in north america for three
quarters in a row so this is basically
stating that it continues to be the
fastest sailing xbox generation as it's
tracking ahead of xbox one 360 in the
original xbox he revealed that it's been
the market again the market leader and
next gen in the next generation market
that's a key statement next generation
switch getting salsa we say in gaming
we've sold more consoles live to date
than any previous previous generation of
xbox the series exit s was the
best-selling next-generation console for
north america and for the quarters
ending december 2021 march 2022 and june
2022
and then he said he referenced
that it means that hey
again that the series exit assets also
the playstation 5 in the three most
recent quarters but not the switch and
then he went on to talk about um xbox
box cloud gaming and he said they've
included over one million new users to
the xbox ecosystem
yeah partnered with epic games shout out
to uh lord bill stilwell over there epic
games to make fortnite available for
free via the browser
said nadella over four million people
have streamed the game to date including
over one million who were new to those
number dudes yeah new to the ecosystem
on that so that that was the initial
talk i know we have so many numbers i
guess i can comment on those it's king
he wants to focus every morning and
choose his violence yes he chooses
i choose violence on sunday so king like
what what's your feeling this is your
topic you know what are your feelings on
these numbers
um in these last three quarters
how many times has the playstation
outsold the xbox series consoles
none
would you say
zero oh
what are you going on
you know what you know king
in the states of north america you know
you know what you know what you do you
know what microsoft here is more than
playstation right now uh-huh
you know what they hear what they do
your button they work oh it doesn't work
your buttons
zero is how many wins sony's had in the
last three quarters
[Laughter]
i told y'all i told you when jeff grubby
grub was his god
no it's the nominee you know people just
woke up that day no i said what was it
specifically that made these people do
these things
and i'm i'm telling you right now i've i
found out exactly what it is i bailed
the mouse i got to the situation i got
to the crux
the cheap gamer is the place they should
give up
all right y'all can sit there talk about
your way for playstation 5. none of
y'all running the stockx none of y'all
you know what going on
i got a picture in the chat
did you post that picture real quick
for what i'll send it to you send it to
you oh yeah find it find it real quick
i'll send it to our chat see if you can
incorporate that you know you know why
they did that playstation plus thinking
because they wanted to sell them
playstations north america
and it's not working it's not working
whatsoever
so soon as addict put that picture show
that picture i'ma tell you exactly why
your numbers ain't right and this is
what's happening here
you guys
right now are at a point
where financially
it's the numbers that's dictating the
loss i told you it was gonna be a
two-prong approach coming in mm-hmm
the financially affluent dudes was gonna
get the series x
and the dudes that exactly this is where
your playstation is at this is where all
your players
[Laughter]
and you guys don't got them so what
y'all did y'all say you know what i'm
gonna go out and i'm gonna buy a series
s
i'm gonna come back i'm gonna make it
bigger okay
thank you thank you make enlarge that
enlarge that for the people with the
cataracts playing the switch
enlarge that for the cataract
this guy right here man i told you dudes
that the worm has turned
it did yo it's it's selling more and you
all know what the 360 was see this is
the fear the 360 was the most successful
xbox right
it's out selling that
why is it all something
right here the glitches that stole chris
they got all your playstations they got
them lined up
this is what i'm talking about this is
what you're talking about being
proactive
this is how you win a generation
are you a blind
so this is the supply chain issue this
is this the playstations is under
this clown
with the firearm i i deemed a race swap
can we change it
look man this is this this is about
thank you addict this is what i'm
talking about
i appreciate this is how we win a
generation
we
this deeper let's dig into the new you
start doing some research yeah the
warehouse is owned by king yeah it can't
be i mean there is there is a theory
that you know it's funny interesting
that microsoft doesn't have these supply
issues and the places are still all
going do you have any cabinets our stuff
is in actual stores your stuff is in
storage
[Laughter]
so yeah the um
the financial sir uh you know you saw
about microsoft's financials but we want
to be fair they also had assistance
yes we are being fair a six percent
decrease year over year in xbox revenue
um also xbox hardware was down by 11
they said the decrease was partially
offset by increase in xbox game pass and
during that quarter i mean during the
investors call they said that um the
company attributed this estimate to
declines in first-party content but
noted that it would be offset by
continued growth with gamepad
subscribers and console sales so xbox
content and service revenue was also
expected to decline in the low to mid
single digits all that being said
then they said um i mean pretty much
nothing that they said it still was xbox
best fiscal year in the history of xbox
so i thought that was interesting like
what's your thoughts i know you don't
really care all that much about the
financial like normal but just in
general about you know xbox what kind of
what your thoughts are
that's cute where are these games i feel
that
man i want to see i want to see one
video on fable i don't want to see a
thousand videos on on uh
where not xbox is down here like look at
the end of the day it's good um you know
if you look at it from the perspective
of where they came from where they are
is is enormous like we went from
you know microsoft
arguably coming off one of the biggest
l's in gaming one of them you know off
of the xbox one generation to be you
know selling two to three ti uh let
times less than
you know where playstation was like if
you want if you were to ask me in like
2017 2016 that they would be neck and
neck with them in north america again
i'll be like ain't no way
no way but you know these generations
are new starts they're not old starts uh
you know people always tell me um you
know p people always tell me stuff like
oh but it's the brain
yeah you know people who say that don't
remember the wii
you coming out and then the switch
destroying both the competition people
don't remember the wii coming out that
that's kind of crazy actually but it's
into one two generations and in a few
generations like look sometimes my
microsoft dropped the ball with the xbox
one and i honestly feel like they're
like look like you know we're going to
do what we can to keep up we're going to
reinvest into the franchises that we
already have and we're going to branch
out and make new studios what we don't
have and this generation is literally
just going to be a generation where we
rebuild we rebuild the whole generation
because because you know this this
generation is an l to a lot of points
and it's like but we got to make sure by
the end of this generation we are at a
good spot for next generation because
people sit here they look at these
things they look at like look we might
talk shout out to slo-mo doing the
lord's work on this um spamming continue
yeah we might talk a lot yeah
we might talk a lot about you know
uh you where these games are in 2022 but
at the end of the day
what is one year compared to a company
that's doing 10 to 15 year
intervals of planning like look they had
a bad 20 22. you know you're gonna play
a lot of third-party stuff on the xbox
brand a little bit of first party stuff
but it's just like look like these
studios don't dedicate what they're
doing for next year they they have five
to ten year road maps it's not here it's
not now it's not tomorrow it's not next
week it's what are we going to be doing
in five years from now because when you
don't you end up like a blockbuster you
end up like these other companies that
toys r us that's went out of business
it's like at the end of the day it's
about what can we do to push right now
we not might be in the greatest position
but what can we do to make us better in
five to ten years and that's what they
did the whole xbox one generation now
you're seeing the fruits of their labor
you're seeing game pass single-handed
people are saying oh look xbox has done
this well considering where they came
from the xbox one generation and it's
not even with a whole lot of first party
titles at the moment
imagine when those games start dropping
and yeah it's the interesting part right
like the the fact that technically the
quarter i mean it did count a little bit
towards the end of last year but let's
be honest right the top of this year was
really not good for first party at all
in them to have
their best fiscal year i mean obviously
hardware stuff's down we're not going to
minimize that but for them to be having
record profit and stuff like that is
interesting you know so i thought that
was interesting i hear what you say in
reference to the to the um the actual
first party output not being technically
what it should be to see any positive
growth but continue adding themselves
yeah it's just like you look at it from
that like you know it's been a pretty
it's been an okay year for xbox like you
know i wish we would have had a little
more output on the xbox one but they're
still selling very well
and that's without these games and keep
in mind these games will come eventually
look people act like the pandemic didn't
happen you know i saw the ufc fight last
night and i was like man if you look at
this video you wouldn't even think we in
a pandemic
it's just like you know people want to
act like that doesn't exist but guess
what it does exist
and regardless how you feel about it you
know people have been jumping through so
many hoops to make games
and you know
there was an adjustment period i think
people are
getting it down a little bit more and
hopefully we'll start seeing some of
these games here in the next year to two
it's always putting in the chat towards
ours it's coming back not right now so
not right now
maybe it'll be it'll be back by december
that's what i heard anyway
so some also before set you up um we did
hear about the other half we got to talk
about the um but you didn't mention the
sony financials is per the wall street
journal sony overall profit in this
gaming segment fell 37 percent
sony sold
here we go 3747
million playstation games through the
quarter which was 26 percent lower than
a year ago it sold 2.4 million
playstation five consoles a bit higher
than wait a second wait a second wait a
second
free r kelly are you still here
where are you at kelly
i'm really really good
you still
here
i i gotta hear this topic again i'm
sorry i have a little bit distracted
i'm texting people so here we go i want
you to turn up the volume on on your
your jail speaker turn it up because you
got the one monotone speaker turn it off
don't do it like that
i'm gonna go a little bit further man
people in the chat put hashtag where you
at kelly oh
where are you at kells yeah definitely
david love it
[Music]
all right so as i was saying so the kid
clearly wants me to repeat this
sorry
sony operating profit in its game
segment fell 37
37. yeah
yo kick off that hat my guy
you do it too much sony also 47.1
million places in games in the quarter
which was 26 percent lower show me your
bill did a year earlier it sold 2006 yes
26 percent lower yes sir it sold 2.4
million places to five consoles a bit
higher than what it sold during the same
period last year sony expects this uh
they sell more with as the supplies
change issues linger subscribers we sold
more than last year but it still wasn't
enough okay yeah subscribers to places
subscribers to playstation plus surface
service also fell slightly from the
quarter before to uh 47.3 percent so oh
it fell down again yeah yes okay
and they just they just got their
servers up and running but it fell back
again
all right let's get it no i mean so
that's pretty much that oh on on the
sony side so solve as it is your turn
talk um
yeah like what do you feel about now we
hear both sides microsoft sony you know
what's your thought process or any of
these numbers
i mean the reality is that when you
really look at
all these numbers on both sides were
amplified during the the pandemic right
where people were really at home and
they really weren't going anywhere and
there was no commerce going on out in
the streets there was commerce going on
you know online and you you you know
your home your order yourself whatever
the case may be
i'll think about them
you said that sorry that was funny yeah
they're disgusting
um
but the fact of the matter is that all
these numbers were super amplified when
it comes to
you know even even game pass numbers the
engagement numbers on both ends of it
people were home fast people
people that don't normally play games on
both sides
we're all of a sudden now playing games
and now we're in a spot in the world
where things are opening up more people
are traveling more people aren't in
front of tvs as much as the people that
the ufc event was looking for like it
wasn't
ufc events for a while have looked like
they've been like crazy so the reality
is that
overall things are opening up more
people who weren't hardcore gamers
sitting in front of the tv anyway are
now going out and not gaming as much so
those numbers are going to diminish now
you couple all of that stuff on both
ends with the fact that we're heading
towards a recession we still have issues
with supply chain yeah we have you know
obviously the one ukraine causing
disruptions economically throughout the
entire world there's ripple effects
when you look at inflation
everything that you earn now is worth
less than it used to be
isn't worthless but it's worth less
speaking of which there is uh i don't
know if you caught this point saw a
great point um in reference to the
sony's early call where they were asking
playstation about um a potential price
raise oh and there was no answer there
was no answer now it's interesting i
bring it up is i have to be honest with
you i'll try to keep my personal
business out
yeah
yeah even though i can't i'm going on
[ __ ] even though i keep my personal
business out as far as where i am
working yeah speak for him cogs
this statement does not reflect
i am just repeating what the news is
obviously better in the oculus quest to
raise their price just recently very you
know touch point very controversial
subject right and the thought process is
you know obviously we see the the
reaction and the thought process is you
know because of inflation right will
other hardware manufacturers have to do
that so it was interesting to me that
sony was asked what like hey would you
you know what yeah you know what's scary
about that the fact that if there's
jack can't be like your car how you left
yo stop that stop that real ski don't
y'all be doing that
[ __ ]
i have nothing to do with that continue
yesterday's price is not today's price
yeah prices
the price of the brick went up the price
of rick went up clearly i think the
scary part about this
is that when you look at if there's
anybody who could take an l on price
because it's the right thing to do in
optics you would think it's meta right
so if the unwillingness to do that is
there
what does a sony do and that's the thing
like that that's one of those things to
me in my mind right microsoft looks at
this situation and looking at the
moments that they've stepped up on a
rake in the past right
it feels like they would look at this
and be like nah we cannot do this no
matter what we have to take whatever l
we're taking on this this hardware we're
going to continue to take this l
the fact that sony would not answer that
is scary in this situation because
you're like you can't find the machine
anyway you have a competitor right you
you i already got them all in your your
warehouse
the fact of the matter is that you have
no it's in anywhere anywhere
and the fact the fact that you
you know
the reality of it is that the console
can't be found out there bro so
you don't want to do anything and and
you have a real competitor now right
which wasn't the case during the xbox
one generation
you don't want to do the
the thing that in terms of optics is the
worst thing you could possibly do right
and the fact that they wouldn't directly
answer that question is worrisome
because it's like okay it means the
situation out here is real this is not
speculation right
and and that is a real possibility that
i think to me you couple that with all
the things that we've had in terms of
chip shortages and the fact that they
haven't been able to sell as many
consoles as you want
and and and
when you think about
the fact that we're already three years
into this console generation
the things that have happened at the
front part of this generation
to me are really going to hinder what
the end product is and at the end of it
a lot of the stuff that's been happening
can create a net negative at the end of
the generation that you can't escape out
from under no matter what happens
whether it was in your control or not
i just think overall
all of these things uh you know a strong
competition
the lack of being able to put consoles
out there
different skus on the xbox size that
really appeal to uh different types of
gamers and the availability of it and it
being a great thing because availability
doesn't matter if people don't care
right people care that's the thing
so to me it really is when you start
looking at this stuff people like oh
it's not a big deal they're still making
profits yes but the fact of the matter
is that there's been enough
things hindering them from where they
want to be that it may not matter at the
end of the generation they're not going
to be where they want it to be period
let me oh let me ask you this i gotta
ask a question after this all right but
can we ask all the questions before you
ask me all right because salva is
touching on some things that's
interesting and again just to look at
the numbers obviously we've seen some
decline on both sides but what you said
was interesting when we talk about the
sony side we forgot to mention they said
the the monthly active users totaled 102
million down from 105 and they said it
appears so it's supposed to be sony's
lowest monthly active users since it
became reported blah blah okay but the
key the key this part was interesting
and it said the gaming and network
service division recorded uh q1 sales of
450 4.5 billion down 11
but they said the decline was attributed
to a decrease in sales of first and
third party titles as well as the full
christmas problem the foil is the fallen
dlc sales for third party so the
question this is the question after you
solve like
because
technically didn't i have more of an
output during that am i wrong like that
but this is it but it goes back it goes
it goes back to the narrative that i've
always had the first party titles
mostly appear appeal more to the
hardcore and the hardcore
have purchased those games right so when
it comes to you're going to have
there's a plateau you reach with those
first party
con
games right it's one of those things
that i've always said all right they're
150 million play playstations out there
whatever vs
why aren't there more sales and you know
i'm not sneezing at 20-plus million
sales spider-man but when you think
about the amount of consoles out there
and you look at a property like a
spider-man right where it's just huge
property why aren't there more sales and
it's because there's just a plateauing
of where the interest stops for certain
things there's so many people who just
buy a playstation to play fortnite to
play or just have netflix netflix
exactly you know what happens but it's
the truth
he talked about justin earlier he'd be a
mess he continued or as a blu-ray player
right or whatever the case may be so
it's to me
it's just one of those things and then
on the third party side the same thing
you don't have
you don't have people just purchasing
games that much and then again when
you're looking at these numbers you have
people that are already speculating and
awaiting your your game pass competitor
right so they know a lot of these games
are going to be
kind of enveloped in this service you
know people are are savvy about their
money they're going to stop and think
like hey you know what let me stop
buying games because they'll probably be
in this service they start having that
so you said no longer a willingness for
the seventy dollar bus off situation
yeah and then the seventy dollar doesn't
seventy dollars bother a lot of people
too so it may not bother the hardcore
for the most part but it would you know
it when you go in and be like this game
is costing me seventy dollars you know
it's it's people have a choice to make
so to me
when you think about those things
happening the impending sort of kind of
transformation of the playstation
ecosystem a little bit and you know you
have this ps plus thing going on now
whatever i just think all of that
coupled together means that the
the transition to how you used to make
money is beginning to happen
and the fact of the matter is all the
criticisms you have of microsoft like
nobody buys games on on xbox anymore
everybody's in game pass and the numbers
are a little
the numbers are a little more murky
right that's going to start being the
case on the playstation side as more and
more people right now yeah so and that's
going to be an increasing thing because
again
on the playstation side you start you
may not see those first party games
there super quick right but you already
see the third and second party things
going on you got straight day one there
you're gonna start seeing more of that
stuff you're gonna start seeing their
the games as a service
to me absolutely have to be there day
one right so
more and more you're gonna have people
one last question that
you're gonna have people that aren't
buying before i lose it sorry um yeah
you got a question for me you're right
how much did they raise the price of the
oculus
um a hundred dollars [ __ ] what
hundred dollars you've been yeah yes sir
and that's all i'm saying on it and i i
i no no no no i'm just not mad to hell
okay so just to get off a hundred
dollars yeah that was the difference
between the xbox um
one and the playstation phone
and we all know if they raise that
playstation five a hundred dollars it's
over you just might as well you sign
sealed the little it's the case
it's the casket it's back into you need
a second job territory right it goes
back hold up is there is there rumors
that that might happen or if it was
asked guys
it was asked it was it was a question
that was asked and playstation didn't
have a comment on it it kind of the way
the way it's it's the way that
it was structured it makes it seem like
because they know these dudes is down
for whatever like they look at the other
dudes and like they just raised it a
hundred dollars it was successful it's a
hundred dollars and it is how many is it
two years removed from its launch just
about yes
instead of lowering the price let's
raise the price and take out some of the
heat sinks let's go
so yeah it's a scary thing
i just honestly did when you look at the
whole picture and you look at
realistically how long these console
generations last i think the stuff that
has happened up front has left
playstation in a position where they're
not position wines are not as strong as
xbox because xbox was again
they they had they had the subscription
ready to go they had all this stuff
ready to go
and playstation was sort of playing
catch up in that regard so regardless to
what i i see playstation in a weaker
position by the end of this console
generation than they were coming in just
because of all the things that have
happened and again being a little late
to the party doesn't doesn't help either
quite as a question for south fargo
in fairness you know we you know we're
painting it's a lot of painting of sony
doom and glooms right now
but you know xbox hardware was down you
know what i'm saying they saw a six
percent decrease in revenue so you know
what what say you solve when you hear
these numbers and then let's be honest
they didn't give the game pass numbers
what they are but they did say
they expect that's king
well all i was saying is like what do
you say when they say they still expect
a decline but they expect it to be
offset
um by game pass numbers as if so do you
think that's bullish of them to say
something like that like where are you
at i mean i think when they start they
already started talking about when you
look at the hardware stuff the hardware
overall
means less to xbox than it does to
playstation playstation the the crux of
their business is still hardware sales
based the way they quantify success is
still sort of
talking about hardware sales and things
of that nature whereas microsoft has
shifted from that so that on the xbox
side it's about game pass and
you know with the with the the samsung
deal where you know we're getting closer
to when they they're going to talk about
whatever that dongle is or whatever the
case may be when i talk about the
samsung deal and the integration into
the new 2022 tvs um
this sort of stuff and and now getting
it to a point where again more and more
people have access to it on their phones
fixing the issue on the ios side where
you can you know you have there's a work
around for that
there people can engage with game pass
in realistically
doable ways now in ways you can't do on
the playstation side so ultimately when
they talk about hardware sales they're
happy that the numbers are moving
but overall you're not going to have as
many people purchasing the hardware even
in japan when we talk about you know the
series s being a more attractive console
in japan the fact of the matter is
they've they've even moved away from
that where it's like it's the switch
maybe but the majority is people on
their phones right
so it is that thing where to me they're
they're just better positioned to
to expand their ecosystem without the
need for the hardware sales to be there
and then when it goes back to
they're still making profit but they're
making less it goes back to the
inflation thing where it's like whatever
you're selling is worth less than it
used to be and you may be selling as
much or more but the money you're
bringing in operating costs and whatnot
the actual profits you're making it's
just less because the money's worth less
um
so that's it both things apply
i i just
the fact of the matter is that microsoft
whether it's dumb luck or whatever the
case may be i don't think it is but they
were more prepared for this type of
scenario than playstation you'd like to
pass the savings on to the consumer sony
likes to pass
so so if this this
this price hike thing if this price like
things becomes a real thing in the in
the console space
it's gonna be interesting because i
again i look at that and i'm like i
don't care what kind of l i need to take
if i wanna playstation side i don't care
what kind of l i need to take i cannot
bring the price of this console up and
also have
people not be able to find it that is
ridiculous
yeah that's it that's a double whammy um
i'll jump in real quick um yeah the
fantastic point so i i hear where you
going um look i think it's a mixed bag
honestly for both sides and and in the
sense that
i understand king's popping off with the
north america giant you know what i said
i get it i get it and to his credit you
know an addict's credit you know we were
told that when the generation
start with the zero
i can't wait we got zero wins in mikasa
but i will i will say look y'all credit
like you know
based on the dominant generation sony
had before with the player before the
xbox one this is impressive this is
impressive from the north american
standpoint right that they have with it
you can see satya's outside he's got a
chest out with this what i thought was
very interesting you know what i'm
saying but um yeah i think it's a mixed
bag for both sides because i think
the pandemic stimulus is over
like i think when the pandemic happened
initially right
everybody was forced to be inside you
had people who were non-gamers like yo
what do we do we can't really go out and
then gaming really benefited exactly
yeah they benefited for that and now
let's be real not that they have record
profits then they act like you're not
gonna keep that keep that momentum
like after you you gotta keep in mind we
had a surge yes during the pandemic yes
and that's because you're not these
people
didn't have anything else to do right so
that's why you had ps4s getting outsold
xbox one s's and x's
so you got these you know these console
manufacturers and you got the services
of record numbers and i think it's kind
of what attica said which is like yo now
that even though it's not officially
over people are outside people are in
the presence of quote unquote trying to
normalize i ain't buying no playstation
hardware still a little down with xbox
too sir but yeah yeah yeah
but to your credit
it's still better than last year
yes i get it i get it
[Laughter]
these dudes don't think it's going to be
at 30 million because we should be
hitting 30 million right now we're at
21.7 yeah yeah bruh ain't nobody copping
and all this all this flip-flopping
these dudes go to stockx get those
playstations out those dudes handy
listen because sony already see that
y'all doing you're willing to pay the
extra so they're gonna put the tax on
top of that so go right now this is what
this is what you want you want the same
energy for the people that went 70
dollar games though 600 consoles if they
raise the price
600 you got them bucks you outside
so go pay the 600 you can afford it is
what what y'all looking for it's worth
it right the console's worth the ssd
but i'm saying this to say this right
you guys have been capping you guys have
been all over the place the numbers in
the metrics show you don't buy no game
right the match party is down first of
all
it's in the bush
you're not purchasing no game you're not
purchasing no games you're not
purchasing no consoles you're not even
in these these services the service
everything is down with y'all what's up
this is your up year right this is the
year where y'all got all the what was
that first party games two first party
games this year and you just launched a
service why the hell do i gotta look
over and notice that y'all haven't won
anything from microsoft after three
months it has been this and in those
three months y'all have launched first
party all over the place outside first
party first party games first party
service this should be a banner year for
y'all and out we out doing you
shout out to phil dominance maximus
aurelius spencer the plan is
working so you are applying the hashtag
no gays doesn't matter because the
financial is still safe yo you know what
you know why it don't matter you know
what fellaini looked over they saw the
metrics too
we saw you drop your gazes like yeah
yeah we gonna do starfield this year we
don't gotta look at them
look at them look at them flapping
around over there
oh my god buying this stuff yo put put
it next year we can just bang them in
the head next year yo
y'all are not a threat no boy it is it
financially is being seen i told you
dude a long time ago the worm has turned
it's over and i know you guys gonna be
like oh king you know your xbox dude
damn right thank you for clarifying that
thank you thank you for clarifying what
teams you play for
king and the xbox one
and i told you it was happening and you
guys was like no king it's never gonna
happen we never yo buckle up
[Laughter]
shot the kid clearly had to get his bars
off that's not pretty much all i got i
just wanted to mention the pandemic
aspect on both sides i thought that yeah
it definitely i felt that little bump
now it's cooling off getting some normal
like those record-breaking numbers are
are definitely not in place and i will
say i thought it was interesting xbox
said
they expect it to be offset by gay
pastor but i would love to know what the
game pass numbers are just 45 million
that's king's game fast numbers but um i
just want to know what those are what
they've been right so far i wouldn't be
transparent with that and let's see you
know we'll see what happens next year
but i thought you know both interesting
both mixed bag for me but that's where
i'm at
anyway moving on oh we got uh some super
chats when we get to the next time yeah
we got a bunch of super chats hold on
let me roll back a little bit
cuz we're still getting black people
let's go right back to the situation
i'm ready to go
let's let's not do that any way to speed
up the process
you've got your bars off sir
not jack five dollar super chat what
about tom cruise as the last black
panther
yo
yo
that's hilarious
we gotta get out of super chat
yeah we got a few we got a few then we
got slow mo back slap two dollars that
i'm dressing up in store for halloween
no doubt do your thing brother do your
thing
then we got spartan ghost 17 two pound
super chat yo the two dudes posing like
they repping their block yeah they
release
some real saints row energy going on
there
[Laughter]
then we got mandingo mcdickens five
dollars super chat enlarge that
warehouse pick for all the sony frauds
that say there's a chip shortage is that
bill spencer and king in that pick
stupid
there we got chaos actual five dollars
chat didn't playstation also not rule
out raising the price of the ps5 when
asked by an investor sony like inflation
it's only like inflation who that
do that
yeah they didn't they did not answer
that question
then we got mandingo big thickets again
five dollars if we chad when i saw that
warehouse pick up phil and king all i
could hear playing in the background is
that tupac song ain't nothing but a
gangsta party
[Laughter]
pull up on me
then we got spartan go 17 two pound
super chat
no he's laughing at the no commerce in
the streets pause sir
there's always that conversation
then we got black addict
spanish
keep him coming keep him coming there we
go raiden blade five pounds super chat
no no yeah of course um it fell back to
47 like it's been stoked for four years
they merged ps plus and ps now only to
drop back to 47 oh and that price check
will be a will be echo chamber okay yeah
there's a lot of thoughts in there um
then we got jeez two dollar super
does the meta price increase help psvr
too
i think it oh man
i mean
it allows them it'll
i don't know
it's always going to help them but i'm
going to tell you this that psvr ii even
though the guts are really the
playstation 5 working
um i still see that headset being no
less than 500 dollars yo i'm looking at
600 now man um
that's six they gotta raise they gotta
throw that hundred on that back jack
next topic please
then we got ty casares uh three dollars
power level over nine thousand black
panther wow
we got raiden blade five pounds which
xbox drops the prices on consoles and
sony won't last ps console if they ever
increase price i really see xbox
dropping price no one ps fan plays ps
games
that's true that's true
ty casaurus again three dollar super
chat playstation fanboy power move
playstation better
that sounds like an argument that
somebody well it's it's a better console
for 600
then we got chaos actual two dollars
super chat seventy dollars is a tank of
gas now
boy that is my guess
that's real yeah and we got carlos
alvarado two dollars super chat monthly
active users down ps plus subs down
point zero one million
down we got tony bryant five dollar
super chat that series s price cut this
holiday is going to be wild did they do
that oh man i'll tell you what man is
ever two hundred dollars
once a little man hits that royal price
of bang them out smurf little man
problem and we got saying five dollars
super chat microsoft slash xbox had a
strategy that that prepared them for a
recession that is true yeah that is true
oh i love the latest super chats perfect
but when you get to it i love the latest
ones spartan go 17 two pounds which that
game pass stimulus package effect is
real
okay so spartan ghost was the last one
that i got
hold on a second let me roll back a
little bit so while he looking for that
we're gonna go right back
we got a member chat from forza legends
been a member for 32 months wow
playstation is dead
laugh my off i don't want to hear any
crazy talk about xbox again
that's fan boys oh yeah shout out to
they're too busy playing twitter to play
games
twitter free that playstation stuff of
course
we ever got the homie nam omar for 12
months thank you sir
save a puppy hit the like button
for the kids
then we got spartan go 17 five pound
super chat jim ryan listening to youtube
motivational speech after falling off
for three quarters free r kelly and
jason schreier still crying over oh my
god
be
nice friend of the show jason tried
thank you thank you absolutely
absolutely
now we got four's a legend member for 32
more you read this one okay that's the
one you read don't care master 20 red
then we got yay baby farmer
[Laughter]
twitter be like welcome to another
episode of kings iron lords podcast
featuring a few other guys thank you for
saying that salute
yeah hey man
that's hilarious but it's so that's how
they be treating it
like yeah don't
chris why are your fans not buying first
party ps gary shout out to christopher
shout out because he coming for chris
christopher hart dude he
how long can playstation keep showing
these lights on wow it's really doom and
gloom out here we got to do it we're
about to shut that door
that we got yeah we were good at it in
the situation what was it the um crystal
dynamics
was wow funny
we splendid
ssd got king thinking about creeping to
the other side wow okay we got a dollar
super drive from cw i'm gonna put awards
for him i'm gonna just add words
cw meant to say was playstation shutting
down tomorrow oh no here we go
contributing
we are caught up no playstations all
right we all caught up
in the topic
hey forge what's going on with handling
it
so we actually have some some positive
news about halo you know
we don't have any any content yet uh
hopefully
i need that we did get a lot of people
leaking what forge looks like and
i gotta tell you guys what they do with
forge is just it's crazy they're making
like doom levels out of forge somebody
built pt in forge already yeah so that's
crazy well see what they have is they
have a script writer in it
where you can actually make items do
what the script says so you can make
like a pistol have rocket shots instead
of just regular ammo like it's crazy
what they're doing sniper shots has
skill shots the things they shoot the
the vehicles and stuff with like
look
i'm not going to jump out of the out of
anything yet but what i will say
is
modes like this is what gave halo 3 the
longevity absolutely i wish we would
have saw this with co-op all together at
launch
because i felt like
people
would be playing that game right now now
it's like this it's like look the launch
of the game had like a ceiling like this
and then the longer it goes the shorter
that ceiling gets now it can still be
mad successful but the longer time goes
the less success he can get at the long
run
no well i feel it's it's interesting i
saw a lot of stuff going on there sorry
i don't know if you got a chance to see
any of the leaks or what's going on with
it yeah i mean again i think i had to
just hit it right on the nose with that
one it's like it's one of those things
where i was the dude that was like
listen the game
the part that i care about is there
but you know looking at this and looking
at again
who would have
with them releasing the game right and
with the multiplayer coming out early
and everybody loving it and whatnot
the furthest thing from my mind was the
content isn't ready even though we
speculated and talked about it when they
came out and it was fire and everybody
was loving it i'm like oh they're ready
they're just they're they're shooting on
all they're kind of shooting on all
cylinders and everything's ready to go
okay fine multi you know co-op isn't
there forge isn't ready but that'll be
fine because the game is there as tight
i just didn't know that they didn't have
a content pipeline or they would they
wouldn't be able to hit whatever they
they you know that their whatever the
the cadence of the content pipeline that
they had in place
so
seeing this now yes it's tough man
because it's one of those things that's
like this complete package looks like
everything is quality right for all you
know by all accounts the uh the co-op
works great you know the ford stuff
that's coming out of it this is the most
powerful forge creator they've ever
built
um and like you know to addict's point
that community has always kept that
alive because in forge if there was
nothing coming out of bungie themselves
or 343 themselves
it is that thing where the community
takes over you have these amazing
creators that make stuff that people you
have an endless amount of new stuff to
play
um
so seeing it now in hindsight and it's
always 20 20 right hindsight's always 20
20.
this would have been a big boon for this
game at launch it really would have but
again i do think
that if the quality is there and they're
able to get their cadence up with the
rest of the game to appease the people
that came to halo for the first time and
expected this sort of this service game
the way they expect you know the cadence
of releases for other service games if
it's able to hit that and all of these
other things are hitting the forge the
co-op i think i think it'd come back
maybe not in the way that it should have
been if it was this strong from the from
the launch
but i think people are always willing to
come back to games like this it's just a
matter of if you can't have 343 coming
out here talking about yeah um you know
like the speculation about the roller
the roller game from the ubisoft where
girl was like yeah after season three is
dead you say that and that turned out to
be real that game is dead already
it's dead already the moment those words
come out of your mouth so
as long as 343 is in it for the long
haul and willing to continue to
improve upon this game and make it where
people want it to be and i think they
will because it's halo they're not going
to let halo die um
i think
the future's positive for this i don't
think it's as big as it could have been
if everything was there at the launch
but i think
if all this stuff works out
people will be playing soft what are you
smoking it's over for
he's he's only stuff he's coming at you
oh that flame inflamed like
let's leave the hyperbole maybe maybe
you stopped playing there's still plenty
of people to play halo like stop wow
forge leaks did you get a chance to see
where you at how you feel don't care
nothing about forge
[Laughter]
i don't i don't buy games to build stuff
if that was the case that i would be
playing minecraft into my eyes not
necessarily about your abilities
about you playing other people's stuff i
don't care about playing other people's
ouija boards i don't care about it
dudes be like yo i build the board over
here i'ma send the team come over and
try it out no
like
no i'm not dude like so i don't i don't
care i don't i don't i don't care at all
like literally so when they was
launching the game and it was like we
don't have forge i was like wasn't
me anyway because if they had to install
list pack and install lap pack i don't
install it i don't care a lot of times i
don't install multi-players to games
because i'm not going to play it
again for a large contingent this is
what they're looking for yeah and they
hear that they're going the full
100
mile for this game in in that aspect
good i'm glad it took his time because
could you imagine if they did put it out
earlier and it wasn't as robust as it
sounds now yeah so i think that they
know that they have to come correct and
i don't agree with flame um i don't
agree that the game is dead i agree that
microsoft put infinite behind it because
they're going to infinitely keep
funneling into this game they're going
to make this game exactly what they
ideal it to be i like the master chief
collection
it's shipped out broken and they stood
with it until they fixed it so until
this game actually starts to hit the
metrics that they want it to hit and
they're going to give you everything and
at some point in time this package is
going to be the package that they wanted
to release
and whenever it hits it
it could hit in in 2024 to be honest
with you um all the stuff that they
wanted to get in there for the launch
itself
pandemic had a real effect especially on
this game when changing the game over to
a game of service type of thing um
it's it doesn't matter
i i think that game pass is their metric
i think game pass allows
that new person
that stepped into game pass
to experience halo
for the first time
how they want it to be if that person
comes in when the game is completely
done
they don't see the bad that you saw all
they see is all this good stuff so
i i don't i think the games of the the
service
changes the ceiling on it i think the
ceiling is absolutely removed i think uh
those people if it starts popping and
i've seen this
if it becomes
something that's popular and it only
takes one or two
uh
twitch guys to uh these guys out here to
gravitate back to it
and changes the whole rhetoric around
that's live services yeah one of those
dudes
say oh my god this forge is so amazing
one of these high streamers there it
goes that's what i want to see at these
see if these guys had that moment too
like oh and i was telling people with
millions of people playing yeah
but it's going to happen here and it's
going to have that same renaissance and
it's going to do it because they see
that sea of thieves can do it and
remember it didn't have a cracking body
in the beginning but it is what it i
mean it was a huge joke right right i
was i was just drugged through the
streets
but it's outperforming
all the first party games that they put
out all the time right so
it's it's going to change this game
doesn't have a ceiling we got to stop
looking at it as the old matrix and the
new metrics is
what's new
today is new for the new people that
just jumped in they're looking for new
engagement not the same old people right
not for you i mean i'm not too much to
add um i saw the mode
look it looks phenomenal it looks
impressive i'm not gonna minimize it it
really looks good like it you know it
looked like man if this was available at
the beginning with this thing event
right it's just like disabled questions
you know saying like i'm just at the
point with them right now where it's
just like i know they didn't leak this
so i'm not coming at them right just
normally
i'll come after
um
what it is is you know somebody leaked
the business out on the inside of a
preview which is interesting that it's
there
it looks phenomenal all i'm saying is i
really don't want to hear anything until
you have a release date that's just
where i'm at i'm at the point where it's
like you're the kid who's always late
for the homework and oh i'm gonna do
better and come back at me at the
marking period when you got your grades
together and everything's finished and
then we could grade where you're at
that's what and i'm not blaming them
this is a leak right the leak looks
impressive but no one in my opinion
won't hear it until you'd say
hey it's coming out blah blah blah yeah
here it is blah blah blah and just you
know bring it back looks
live service could come back i've said
it a thousand times
this looks phenomenal let's get the the
the co-op let's get the um
battle royale let's get this single
player like let's do that whole
take a kick in this thing put it all
together
say yo you know halo infinite reborn
reforged whatever you want to call it
put that bad boy out in the streets and
then holler at me from right now i just
don't want to hear everybody until until
it's out that's what i'm trying to say
i'm not trying to be disrespected this
thing looks amazing i saw them put a
master chief character full screen ain't
doing pt they're doing doom
my head just when is it out
[Laughter]
with this out holla at me otherwise i'm
over here i'm doing the rocker i'm doing
this until it come out then because it
it's just one of those things i think
that live service
it's a it's an ebb and flow right and i
just i'm always going to be mad at them
because they had the people at the palm
of their hand and like saul said when
they was out
everybody was talking hey you know the
king was back we was in party chats we
uh uh we like oh the pipeline crazy
there's gonna be bad maps it's gonna be
nice
that's it
here you go that's it
okay and that's it that's all listen if
anybody i want them to succeed i'm
always going to be tough on things i
love
i want them to succeed just don't talk
until it's ready that's all i'm at
that's it
that's what i got let's roll up um let's
do the soup i'll do the uh poll and the
way you plug up the super chats yep
perfect no doubt no
i can't i don't go back out oh my bad
[Music]
[Laughter]
i wanted to go back to the only number
that counts
[Laughter]
you're ridiculous with that north
american stuff oh anyway
but that's let me let me say this right
even during the xbox one generation a
lot of times we always quantify things
on a worldwide basis right yeah but i'll
be honest i live in the states i want to
see how it's doing in the states and in
the states even during the xbox one
generation the numbers are much closer
than people
ever acknowledged oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah and now
i i'm now i where did i read this i
think the difference in console sales
console sales in north america
is in the region of like 500 000
consoles that's it it's impressive and
this is the thing adam said
because i gotta to my own horn i tell
every people every generation is a new
it's a clean slate yeah it's a clean
slate it doesn't matter nintendo wii
is a prime example the weed of the wii u
to the switch
yeah we seen this this this like it it
literally didn't yeah it was just we was
the most dominant like you couldn't find
that thing in the toy store they're like
wii u so if we were we you'd be like yo
it's gonna continue to go continue to
dominate will you happen and they pop
like that then it's all nintendo's over
it's a wrap there's nothing they could
do here come and switch right you could
never predict these things so for the
people who looked at the last generation
and automatically counted xbox out like
this has nothing to do there's no games
hey don't do that don't do that be nice
shout out to brat don't do that i know
y'all got y'all issues i know attic and
king got y'all issues
but i'm trying to play neutral here
shout out to this album but look at the
end of the day
the attic at him i to get y'all out of
the room and peace out but um look at
the end of the day the thing is this if
you looked at the xbox one
oh god
oh so at the end of the day
with the xbox one you know generation
you know if you looked at it it was
really blake right it looked like they
didn't even care about games
whatever whatever
the messiah fell
shout out to the dominance you know say
it did he stay in the messiah
of social media on twitter this little
echo chamber right you continue to say
no games no games you know live service
and all this stuff is bad and then when
we're seeing what's actually happening
with the numbers and stuff like that and
then we see unless in xbox's case right
that they still kind of deficient in the
first party but they're having any
success like that to me is just like wow
like you don't say it's really
mind-blowing yeah and then like we
talked about on the flip side where we
as the hardcore we value the first party
baggage we values like yo and then
you're like damn don't i'm trying to i'm
gonna sell it
right like so then you're looking at and
then we had justin all right and we like
yo live service trash this garbage in
esports did you see where these things
are trending right and you're like yo
this is mind-blowing that's what i'm
trying to say it's generational and they
even the example justin gave with kids
and the mobile and these this next
generation of gamers that's all they
know
right i'll tell you this yo my my nephew
sold my steam there my niece they saw my
steam deck yesterday right
and i and he was like is that a new
switch i was like no it's not a new
switch this is to play steam games pc
games
and he's like oh
captain moving
like moving fact like the console and
the you know joy is the dinosaur like
these kids is on these it's so crazy
just to charge this stuff try to tell
people when it comes to that steam stuff
it's like look like unless they got that
pokemon the fact that like a lot of
these younger audiences the majority of
these consoles are going to go to they
don't care it's saying like we talking
like you just made a good point we talk
about steam deck right i know solvers
you know lord steam deck right because
it's the perfect console the power the
customization all that he could do but
you put the steam deck in little joey
here little joy like where the pokemon
at where's the mario kart or where's the
whatever you know what i'm saying he
might gravitate towards the switch still
so it's just interesting that that
separation that we got to be careful as
gamers in on twitter like yo just
because we like right that don't mean
that's where the industry going and
sometimes these numbers what king said
reflects that sometimes the hardcore we
over value things we like and the
industry shows different so i thought
that was interesting but anyway get this
poll popping with the recent value in
the stuff
with the recent announcement of black
tom
oh my god hard to get a ticket hard to
get yo you don't do the phone back to
flex don't do the flex
with the reasons
shout out to brian easy so he wants to
see pokemon show him pokemon yeah that's
us forcing it as parents the kids don't
want to do it though you got to go the
kids are picking up they phone right
east i feel you i'm hardcore with you
steve decker's fire but the kids is like
yo way i could play this at over here
you know yeah most popular games in
history right now is roblox
does any hardcore game okay about that
nobody's more bigger than him that is us
so it is what it is but anyway look new
ip poll with the recent announcement of
a black panther game in early
development how confident are you that
ea is backing the title eight
not confident ea has a lot to prove when
it comes to a commitment to
single-player focus games that are not
micro transaction heavy
kings laughing be very confident jedi
fallen order proved that a commitment to
single-player quality and respect of
licenses
what happened
now finish finish oh my god with y'all
no finish just finished because all i'm
going to do is all right you're about to
be taken
i want you to describe everything
what is your fault up there for addict
what is your fault oh you're doing the
same thing i want you to tell me
everything you see and everything that
you hear
and i just don't know what's going on
anyway back to the poll
be very confident jedi fallen off order
proved that a commitment to single
player game quality and respect of
license ip can exist or c i don't care
it's all good they make it a new black
panther but i'm keeping an eye out on
that character
it was crazy i came up with this pole
before all this craziness came out so
that was kind of hilarious with the chat
salute to everybody that's rocking out
you already know we're doing a super
chats we're doing outro from we do it
first
real quick
we got rocker corey dollar super chat
this is what happens when your ceo
doesn't even play games playstation has
no real strategy for the for the players
hashtag lying jim ryan jesus
jesus
we got gamer by choice member for 33
months thank you brother i appreciate
that i have to say i'm very surprised
xbox is doing so well this generation
after the xbox one error cog meta got
you having the dodge questions but i
respect you having a combo based on your
position salute
we got raiden played by possibly chad
let's help sony every time we see them
ps dudes on twitter
send them back to play games and not
twitter if playstation was supposed to
like twitter playstation would be up
forte remember for 32 bucks
positive news and halo wake me when halo
infinite 2 releases jesus or at least
more story content i admire the effort
but where was this at launch yeah agreed
raiden blade member for 18 months
love iop i saw four clips via plume it
looks mad for forge but what i but what
i have seen this is is going to be from
what i have seen this is going to be
worth it i want to create and forge yeah
i mean again more power to you i don't i
can't do none of that stuff but it's
awesome that they can build all that on
there yeah
raiden blade again two pound super chat
gravity ball mode which was created and
forged i believe yeah there were certain
modes that stuck
that were actually just built in forts
to begin with
then we got necromancers ale ten dollar
super chat it's called griff
yes
i love griffin
it's like little stuff like that
infection where is all that three four
three
imagine if it was launched and it could
just continue
no they don't normally put that in at
launch like all of halo it's usually
been that's like a special event but man
we we down here a year where is is
grifball yeah that's true
you got necromancer zale 10 super chat
cog quit fence sitting tell us what we
want to hear not what we need to yeah
next
[Laughter]
then we got ready to play two pop super
chat chris who's still playing straight
unlike halo so shh i guess it's back and
forth between christopher hardwick
battling strange versus yeah
then we got
nc ghost of low road
okay
mc ghost
five dollars super chat the ps5 being
held hostage by little green cards the
book of the of the book of dominus they
bragged about sharing games because they
can't afford to buy them obviously wow
man preach it from the book of acts okay
okay
then we have splendiferous two dollars
if we chat jim ryan in xbox basement
playing forza hot wheels
oh my god jesus
all right then we have
lord metro two dollar super chat switch
plus live alive we are gaming great here
yeah that's what's eating baby switching
right now
uh
it's that nice you meant that low about
you i'm gonna attempt something i don't
know if it's gonna work all right so
i do have my live live uh video what's
funny actually
i don't i don't know why they named it
like that like because it is japanese
and weird but
how this is going to work is after the
podcast it's supposed to premiere i
don't know if it's going to work or not
all right
never done it
what's funny is i
i put it for four o'clock i didn't
realize we'd go over four classes so now
we're gonna see if it breaks i had to
delete it
just so i could try this because like
i don't expect the views to be crazy on
this because it's a week late but it's
kind of like an experimental review and
i think a lot of you would like the game
so just for the clarity once the iop
stream lens should go straight over
there
it should take them right there it
should okay
no doubt no doubt so are we good yeah
we're good caught up no doubt oh wait
the other one oh one splint difference
two dollar super chat and he holding the
controller upside down no jim no yeah
yeah
we gaming over here the playstation on
the wrong side i forgot where they had
that i was fighting somebody
i got the new playstation 6.
i thought it didn't exist
the poly stations
what's funny
and there you go
wow
when i showed the stock clock uh that i
was uh dealing with king at the
beginning
it was reversed so i had to go into the
settings on zoom and mirror my images
just so he could be right that is
hilarious
anyway we got that out the way shout out
to the legendary justin jacobson jmj
attorney of esports educating us on the
trends the man came prepared a wealth of
knowledge fun gamer look out for him
more man he's a rising star in this
industry check i appreciate those for
actually listening i know we have the
educational things sometimes some people
want to come in for the topics and i get
it you know it's not everything for
everybody but at least for the people
who stayed and not rushing is it going
to be over yet
like i repre we appreciate that because
we're going to do that from time to time
sometimes you got to learn what's
actually going on in the industry from
the sources especially if you play games
if you play games
go get that bag
the thing about like you know i know
sometimes uh a good portion of the
viewership don't like like the
educational stuff but we want to be a
one-stop for a lot of things
and in order to do that sometimes some
of you ain't gonna like the content and
you know we we always say well there's
always next week's podcast i encourage
you to learn about the industry that you
that you clearly you care about because
you in these chats yeah or just saying
you see the topics on the side you just
wait until your topic confident you know
whatever whatever it's all good you know
what i'm saying but anyway salute lord
addict where can the fine people find
you what you got going on sir before a
stream that might may or may not
transition
we we we it should it should be fun i
don't know we'll see like i've tried to
do it like three times in a row to
streamers and it's not working so i'm
like i'm gonna try it with our stuff
let's see how it works with our stuff um
i will be amping up uh our presence on
stuff like tick tock and stuff uh
you know we we we gotta do a little bit
better on that it's just hard to balance
everything like social media
it's just like you know i try my best to
like throw little things out on twitter
like every now and then like you know
what are you playing yes or you know try
to get the feedback of the viewership to
what who you want on the podcast but
that's not easy to manage that manage my
twitter manage my job you know it it
it's not good man it's not good but all
right so like i said uh there will be
if it doesn't come on off to the show
just go over there and watch it it'll be
it'll be live at that time uh you know i
appreciate everyone come through we had
up to like 650 people yeah uh you know
you guys came through
we need we need dirt back on iop dirk is
a member of addict's show yeah go watch
it go watch
love the educational stuff getting a lot
of insight that i haven't heard anywhere
else for mobbie thank you that really
means a lot to us well my mother salute
really appreciate that
yeah we will get more people on uh you
know uh we did go on a couple months of
uh it's just us thing and we're gonna
still continue that mentality uh but we
will make sure we get unique guests that
you guys can learn different aspects
from and obviously we'll bring back the
the classics you know i do want to do
more
collaborations with other podcasts yes
uh that's on the agenda but we're booked
up to like november yeah so
it's it is it is what it is at that
point i want to thank king for taking
the l on the podcast you know yeah
he uh he he he's definitely going to
especially with this god award oh my god
we're getting closer
and closer
[Laughter]
so yeah that's that's right that revenue
stream down
all you looking at is the writing on the
wall
see this is the thing people don't think
about god of war is gonna sell well
amongst the hardcore and if they bundle
it with a console and people could find
that console for the holidays it'll sell
there but it's not selling beyond a
certain point
yeah and they gotta be able to bundle it
and wrap it and because they can't get
their stuff up because they stock and
they chip shortage your boys sleeping
the next year
you flipping with your boys oh you're
still rocking with that
right there
i'm just watching you yeah you all hyped
up all the way in ain't even august yet
you still hyped up
calm down youngin
i've seen this happen too many times
this is the scary this the part in the
scary movie trip
it's cool
i got four minutes for the show's up go
all right
anyway so that's it all right cool no
doubt soft yeah thanks to everybody for
the condolences i really appreciate it
uh it's
it's always hard but stuff like this
happens so thank you i appreciate that
um what else what else what else look
out for i'll be recording with lady
april a little bit later on today lord's
minute so look out for our impressions
of the uh the gta 6 leaks oh and uh i'm
gonna be talking about that a little gta
today so uh it'd be interesting so look
out for that later in the week
uh you know where i'll be i'll be on
that steam neck baby i'm gonna play that
arkham origins
okay i threw on a bunch of stuff i'm at
the point i'm just throwing anything on
there to see what sticks and what works
and what doesn't pc match the race now
all right listen bro i i can't i don't
have time i love that yo dude i i turned
on my xbox for my niece last night and
i'm looking at my library the library's
damn near 800 strong
when am i gonna win
no doubt attic is giving us the sandman
hook um he's like yo we got a joke you
got to get up everybody i don't know
what's going to happen all right 45 all
right hold on let's speed through this
yes okay i'm done thank you
look you got three
[Music]
thank everybody for hanging out with me
yesterday in combat talk with the king i
really appreciate everything that you
guys do work um working on some stuff uh
catch me on twitter king david otw the
same name that's on xbox so
if you want to play video games and hang
out with me over there i'm over there uh
on my playstation whenever i can
actually contact their customer service
this man has the contacts the customer
service issue
i'm starting without believe this
customer service problem
it's been a year compelling it's not
compelling for me to force me to do you
know how you got to be forced to do
something yes there's nothing forcing me
to do anything over there obviously the
numbers dictated
the playstation hasn't been turned on
and i need to turn my playstation on
pause
so again that's our xbox 360 level one
over there uh to know that's me it's the
one with the ape escape little icon i'm
the little monkey with the little with
the little fraud alert two minutes
i'm looking like this like this this is
me
everybody else over there is not
purchasing games so um it was a great
show yes i want to thank uh everybody
that did come out
uh
please look forward to me and attic yes
doing a whole lot more stuff
um because i definitely want to get
y'all guys in some games some some
hundred player games some 20 play games
50 play games
and uh you know and put this work on you
especially for y'all i want to catch you
in these streets oh kelly
running across the yard won't hit you
with the with the bb gun pop out
because no doubt you already know
cognito here is kicking me off the show
so look that's all we got everybody
enjoy next sunday should be another big
one tune in yeah it should be a nice
treat everybody enjoy your sunday we out
there
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
you